GOOD AFTERNOON I LIKE TO CALL
THIS ON THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
EMPLOYMENT.
EATING TO ORDER -- WE WILL START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE -- AND
RESPECT FOR OUR SENATORS HERE'S
WELL AS OTHERS THAT ARE HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE -- AND SO I'D LIKE
TO INVITE UP SENATOR JACKSON'S.
TO PRESENT SB ONE SEVENTY ONE
AND OF COURSE ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM -- WELL ESTABLISHED THAT
AND AND PROCEED TO CONVERT THANK
YOU SO SENATOR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
ONE SEVENTY ONE IT'S A BILL VERY
SIMILAR TO A BILL THIS COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY SAW LAST YEAR.
IT'S A BILL TO FIGHT PAY
DISCRIMINATION WITH DATA.
WITH INFORMATION.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO PAY A
QUICK EQUITY FOR WOMEN AND
MINORITIES WE CAN'T FIX WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW.
IT WILL REQUIRE EMPLOYERS WITH A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES ARE MORE
SHOVEL FAIRLY ROBUST COMPANY. TO
MORE -- EXCUSE ME TO SUBMIT A
PAY DATA REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING.
OUTLINING THE COMPENSATION AN
HOUR'S WORK TO OF EMPLOYEES BY
GENDER.
RACE ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY.
AND THE GOAL IS TWO FOLD FIRST
TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS TO
ANALYZE THEIR OWN PAY PRACTICES
AND ALLOW FOR SELF CORRECTION.
PUT THAT MIRROR IN FRONT OF YOUR
FACE AND SHE JUST EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
AND IF YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING
THAT IS UNLAWFUL OR CREATES DIS
DESPARD WORKING OPPORTUNITIES
MAKE THOSE CORRECTIONS.
NOBODY ELSE HAS TO REALLY KNOW
ABOUT IT YOU FILE YOUR ANNUAL
REPORT.
YOU MAKE THE CORRECTIONS AND YOU
OF ACCOMPLISH WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO DO.
AND NUMBER TWO IT WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING TOGETHER IMPORTANT
DATA THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SEE
PATTERNS OF WAGE DISPARITIES IF
THEY EXIST.
AND IF THEY NOTICED DEVIATIONS
OR OUT LIARS TO BE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE FURTHER AGAIN WITH
THE HOPE THAT IF COMPANIES SEE
THAT THEY ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE
WITH OUR FAIR PAY LAWS.
AND WHERE THERE'S DISPARITY IN
INCOME AND JOB SEGREGATION THAT
THEY WILL MAKE THOSE CORRECTIONS
IN IT ESSENTIALLY AN INCENTIVIZE
BUT REALLY VOLUNTARY WAY.
SO THE INFORMATION THEN WOULD
ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT IF THEY REQUESTED.
THE BILL IS CLOSELY MODELED
ACTUALLY AFTER EFFORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
<c.red> SHOULD SAY PRE TRUMP.</c>
NOT RECOGNIZING THAT UNEQUAL PAY
IS OFTEN HIDDEN TO EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A
PROPER PROPOSED REVISION TO A
DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT.
THAT LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTING FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS.
IT'S THE EMPLOYER INFORMATION
REPORT KNOWN AS THE E. E. O..
ONE AN AIDE EXPANDED IT TO
INCLUDE THE REPORTING OF PAY
DATA BY RACE AND GENDER
BEGINNING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SIMPLY EXPANDING REPORT THE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
YEARS.
SO IT'S NOTHING NEW IT JUST
SIMPLY ADDS TWO CATEGORIES RACE
AND GENDER.
BUT IN AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAID
EQUAL PAY EFFORTS BACK BY
PUTTING A WHOLE TO THIS NEW RULE.
THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
SUIT.
ARGUING THAT THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT BUDGET LACKED A GOOD
CAUSE TO STAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PAY DATA COLLECTION.
BUT IN MARCH A FEDERAL JUDGE
ORDERED THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH COLLECTING
THIS IMPORTANT DATA.
CITING THE EXTENSIVE PREPARATION
STUDY AND IN PORT THERE WENT
INTO THE CREATION OF THIS DATA
REVISION.
AND DECLARING THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT BUDGETS DECISION TO
HALT THE PROGRAMME.
ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS.
SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER HEARD
ABOUT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
I'M SURE.
BUT IN THIS CASE THE COURT
ACTUALLY MADE A RULING.
AND THIS DISH DECISION MAY BE
APPEALED BUT NONE THE LESS THE
COLLECTION OF THIS IDENTICAL
PAID OUT OF REQUESTED UNDER THIS
BILL.
IS NOW UNDER WAY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN SB ONE SEVENTY ONE WILL
ENSURE THIS DATA IS ALSO IN THE
HANDS OF OUR STATE AGENCIES.
AN EMPLOYER MAY COMPLY WITH THIS
BE ONE SEVENTY ONE BY SIMPLY
SUBMITTING TO THE STATE A COPY
OF THEIR E. O. ONE FORM.
THIS IS ABOUT AS EASY AS IT GETS
TO COMPLY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BASED ON
SOME OF THE INFO --
MISINFORMATION OUT -- FOR TO
KNOW WHAT THIS BILL IS NOT.
IT IS NOT ABOUT PUBLIC EXPOSURE.
OR TRAINING.
SOME MIGHT THINK THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA AND I DON'T
NECESSARILY DISAGREE.
BUT I DON'T FEEL THAT WE NEED TO
QUITE GET THERE AT LEAST AT THIS
FIRST POINT PRELIMINARILY IT MAY
BE SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO GOING
FORWARD.
BUT I LIKE TO THINK THAT MOST OF
THESE COMPANIES DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE LAW SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW ALL.
AND NOT THAT IT'S INTENTIONAL
THAT MAY BE WRONG BUT I'M
WILLING TO GIVE IT A CHANCE AND
SO THIS BILL REALLY ISN'T ABOUT
INCENTIVES.
ARE THIS BILL WILL NOT EXPOSE
INFORMATION THAT IS INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE BY BUSINESSES NOR
WILL EXPOSE EMPLOYEES PRIVATE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC.
I'VE EVEN TAKEN THE UNUSUAL STEP
OF PROHIBITING A PUBLIC RECORD
ACT DISCLOSURE.
SO AGAIN MY GOAL HERE IS TO GET
COMPLIANCE AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT
THIS WILL BE.
AS EFFECTIVE AWAY AND IF NOT
FRANKLY I'M PREPARED TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS A HARSHER
STICK -- THAN THE CARROT THAT
WERE OFFERING THE LIMITING OF
PUBLIC AVAILABILITY OF THE
REPORTS IS SIMILAR TO ACTUALLY
WHAT OCCURS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WHERE THEY'VE HAD NO ISSUES WITH
ON TOWARD DISCLOSURE OF THIS
DATA.
IN THE FIFTY PLUS YEARS SINCE
THIS OP FORM IS BEEN REQUIRED.
BUT WHAT THE DATA WILL PROVIDE
AS I MENTION IS A BIRD'S-EYE
VIEW TO PAY DISPARITIES AND
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION.
BUT IT DOESN'T DO IT IN A
GRANULAR WAY SO YOU CAN IDENTIFY
ANY PARTICULAR PERSON THE
INFORMATION HERE IS NOT INTENDED
AND CANNOT BE USED TO ENFORCE
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY ACT.
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING AT LARGER
CATEGORIES FROM THE THIRTY
THOUSAND POINT OF FOOD VIEW.
AND THE KIND OF INFORMATION.
ABOUT SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK
BONA FIDE REASONS FOR PAYING ONE
EMPLOYING MORE THAN ANOTHER
ISN'T ASKED FOR IN THIS REPORT.
EMPLOYERS WILL NOT BE EXPOSED IN
THAT MANNER I KNOW WE'VE HEARD
OLD THE SKY IS FALLING IT IS NOT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THE EO ONE
FORM FOR YEARS.
THIS IS A TOOL TO SHED LIGHT ON
TRENDS AND THE BIG PICTURE.
THIS IS A MEASURE TO ENSURE WE
MOVE TOWARD THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
NOT ONLY WILL PAY BUT OF CLOSING
THE GAP IN JOB SEGREGATION THAT
WE KNOW EXISTS BUT HOPEFULLY
COMPANIES WHEN THEY SEE IT
EXISTING WITHIN THEIR OWN
ENTITIES.
WILL MAKE THE NECESSARY
CORRECTIONS THIS IS A BILL.
BASICALLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
LAWS FOLLOWED IN WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I TALKED THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON'S IMPOSSIBLE MOMENT AND
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND SECRETARY.
KALRA HERE FLORA.
CARILLO.
YEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER THREE OF US FOR MR.
THANK YOU -- WE DO HAVE QUORUM
ESTABLISHED AND AS WE GO ON
CHAIR WITNESSES SAID THE THE WAY
WE OPERATE HERE AS WE ALLOW UP
TO SIX MINUTES.
YOU CAN DIVVY IT UP ANY WAY YOU
CHOOSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE ALL
THE SIX MINUTES WE DON'T USE BUT
PLEASE -- PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSICA STENDER AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL -- I'M
GONNA FOCUS MY TESTIMONY A
LITTLE BIT ON THE BACKGROUND
ABOUT HOW THIS BILL CAME ABOUT
AND WHY IT WILL HELP ADDRESS
SOME OF THE MAJOR CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS. TO THIS GENDER AND
RACIAL WAGE GAP THAT WE SEE
PERSISTING OVERTIME AND CLOSING
AT A VERY SLOW PACE.
FIRST I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE EXTENSIVE STUDY AN ANALYSIS
THAT WENT INTO THE FEDERAL RULE
THAT SENATOR JACKSON MENTIONED.
THE PROCESS STARTED BACK IN
TWENTY TEN WHEN THE EOC JOINED
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
IDENTIFY WAYS TO IMPROVE
ENFORCEMENT OF OUR FEDERAL PAY
DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
THEY ENGAGE THE NATIONAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCES TO ISSUE A REPORT
THAT THAT BASICALLY RECOGNIZE
ENFORCEMENT VALUE OF COLLECTING
THIS KIND OF PAY DATA BROKEN
DOWN BY SEX RACE AND ETHNICITY --
THE EOC ENGAGE IN A FIVE YEAR
VALUATION PROCESS WHICH INCLUDED
PUBLIC COMMENT CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS A PILOT
STUDY AND THEY CAME OUT WITH
SOME TECHNICAL RECOMMENDATIONS
AS TO THE MOST AFFECTED PAY DATA
TO COLLECT.
AND THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO DO
IT TO CREATE THE LEAST BURDEN ON
EMPLOYERS SO THAT'S WHAT WENT
INTO THIS FORM THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL NOW IS IS -- BASED ON THIS
CALIFORNIA BILL SO WHY IS THE
INFORMATION IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EQUAL PAY WERE OFTEN
TALKING ABOUT ONE WOMAN AND ONE
MAN OR ONE PERSON OF ONE RACE
AND ONE PERSON ANOTHER RACE.
PERFORMING SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
WORK BUT BEING PAID DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS AND THAT IS A VERY
COMMON PROBLEM THAT WE KNOW IT
EXISTS -- BUT ANOTHER PROBLEM
THAT ISN'T SO DISCUSSES THIS
ISSUE THAT CENTER JACKSON
MENTIONED OF OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION WHERE BY WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE OFTEN
PREDOMINATED IN OVER
CONCENTRATED.
IN LOWER PAYING OCCUPATIONS
WITHIN A COMPANY OR EVEN ACROSS
AN INDUSTRY.
ON THIS CAN BE DUE TO A VARIETY
OF FACTORS SOMETIMES UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS A RECRUITING HIRING AND
PROMOTION PRACTICES AND OTHER
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THAT
EMPLOYERS THEMSELVES MAY NOT
EVEN BE AWARE.
EXIST WITHIN THEIR COMPANIES SO
AS YOU'VE HEARD THIS TYPE OF PAY
DATA THIS HIGH LEVEL DATA WILL
HELP COMPANIES IDENTIFY THESE
TRENDS THAT ARE OFTEN UNDETECTED
AND THEN TAKES STEPS TO CHANGE
THEIR COURSE -- THEY MIGHT NOT
NECESSARILY SHOWN EQUAL PAY ACT
VIOLATION BUT THEY WILL PROMPT
COMPANIES POTENTIALLY CHANGE
THEIR PAY PROMOTION HIRING
PRACTICES TO BETTER REPRESENT
WORKERS AT ALL LEVELS OF PAY
WITHIN THEIR COMPANIES.
BUSINESS IS A RECOGNIZE THE
UTILITY OF DOING THIS WE'VE SEEN
A LOT OF EXAMPLES IN THE PUBLIC
OF BIG COMPANIES INCLUDING SALES
FORCE THE GAP STARBUCKS NAME A
FEW.
THAT ARE VOLUNTARILY DONE THESE
TYPES OF AUDITS FOUND THESE
DISPARITIES AND THEN MADE
CHANGES WITHIN THERE'S THEIR
INTERNAL PAY SYSTEMS TO BETTER
REPRESENT PEOPLE AT ALL AT ALL
LEVELS.
AND IN FACT EARLIER THIS YEAR
THIRTEEN COMPANIES PLEDGED TOOK
THE CALIFORNIA PAY EQUAL PAY
PLEDGING COMMITTED TO DOING THIS
TYPE OF AUDIT VOLUNTARILY O WE
SEE THAT BUSINESSES HAVE.
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS HAVE BY THE AUDIT AND WHAT
IT CAN REALLY SHOW THEM ABOUT
THEIR OWN COMPANIES AND THEN
FINALLY IT GIVES A D. F. E. H.
MORE DATA WITH WHICH THEY CAN DO
EVALUATIONS ANALYSES OF PAY
WITHIN A COMPANY BUT ALSO ACROSS
INDUSTRIES.
AND IF OVER TIME THEY IDENTIFY A
COMPANY WITH SIGNIFICANT PAY
DATA -- DISPARITIES OVER TIME
THEY CAN CHOOSE TO DO THAT DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND SEE WHETHER
WARRANTED IF THEY ARE THEN
THAT'S GREAT THE COMPANIES ON
VIOLATION OF ANY LAWS.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT THEN THEY CAN
THEN ENFORCE THE LAWS AS THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO DO.
SO WE THINK THIS PAID REPORTING
IS AN EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE TOOL
THAT WILL HELP INCREASE --
EFFORTS TO HELP COMBAT THE PAY
DISPARITIES THAT WE KNOW EXIST
AND FOR THAT REASON WE ARE DRY
BOTH AND YOU.
THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHOWS WITH
CROWLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
OF A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL --
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OVER THE LAST
BIT ABOUT -- FEAR PACE ALL KEEP
THROUGH THESE COMMENTS BRIEF BUT
I THINK THAT SOME HIGHLIGHTS ARE
WE'D SAID UP UNTIL RECENTLY THAT
WAS GOING TAKE ABOUT FIFTY YEARS
TO CLOSE THE GENDER PAY GAP.
BASED ON DATA FROM TWO THOUSAND
TO TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN IT'S
A HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS NOW.
SO NOW ALL THE LAWS THAT WE'VE
DONE SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT.
FULLY TAKEN EFFECT BUT IT GIVES
YOU A GOOD IDEA ABOUT.
NO MATTER ALL THE GREAT LAWS WE
HAVE ON THE BOOKS WE NEED TO DO
MORE IN ENFORCEMENT.
OUR DATA SHOW THE ONLY ABOUT
6212% OF PAY DISPARITY IS
STUDENT OUT RIGHT BY.
OR DISCRIMINATION [inaudible]
THE MAJORITY OF THIS IS
PERPETUATION OF THE STATUS QUO
INCLUDING A JOB SEGREGATION.
WOMEN IN ADDITION TO MAKING ON
AVERAGE ABOUT 80% OR EIGHTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR AMOUNT OF OF
MEN FOR WOMEN OF COLOR IT
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE LEGAL TEAM
THIS IS LESS THAN FIFTY CENTS.
ON THE ON THE DOLLAR I'M THEY
USUALLY GENERALLY NEED EXTRA
DEGREES.
IF THEY GO TO COLLEGE TO MAKE A
SIMILAR SALARIES SO THEN THEY
ALSO THIS GETS INTO THE STUDENT
LOAN DEBT THAT IS DIFFICULT TO
GET OUT OF AND ALSO THINK OF
THIS IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
WORKING.
WOMEN.
THAT ARE USING SOCIAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT WOULDN'T HAVE TO
IF THEY WERE BEING PAID FAIRLY.
AND WERE IN.
SOME BETTER JOBS.
I'M JUST A NOTE ON THE THE THE
APPEAL FROM THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
LAW CENTER.
TWO THE SUSPENSION OF OF THE EO
ONE AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL THAT
THE PLAINTIFF LABOR COUNCIL FOR
LATIN AMERICAN AND ADVANCEMENT.
REPRESENTS TWO MILLION LATINO
LATINA TRADE UNIONISTS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
RELY ON THE EO ONE FORM.
AND WITH THE USE IT FOR IS THE
WORK THEY USE IT TO GO AND WORK
WITH EMPLOYERS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF OF KNOWN
LITIGATION WAYS THAT YOU CAN GO
AND AND YOU KNOW USE THE STATIC
AND IT'S NOT GONNA SHOW YOU WHAT
THE THE GRANULAR LEVEL -- WE
NEED TO HELP EMPLOYERS DO THE
RIGHT THING ENCOURAGE THEM TOOK
TO LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE IT NEVER
NOW THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONALLY
TOOLS.
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS HAS PUT OUT IN
TERMS OF HERE'S SOME THINGS WE
KNOW YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO
DISCRIMINATE BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP YOU MAKE THINGS RIGHT.
WE NEED TO CHANGE THE STATUS QUO
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
BILL.
THANKYOU BOTH VERY MUCH -- IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT USED TO LABOR COMMITTEE --
SERRA.
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
JUST PARK WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
CAN WEARING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIANS LIMóN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
RENEE BAYARDO ESSAY YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PAUL YOU ARE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL KEY ACLU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JULIA PARISH LEGALLY THAT WORK
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE TAKE A SEAT IN THE SAME
RULES UP UP TO SIX MINUTES.
DIVVIED UP ANYWAY YOU LIKE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO USE ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S WHY THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART OF TRY.
TO SENATE BECOME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THE THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
DOES NOT SUPPORT.
A DISCRIMINATION -- THE CHAMBERS
WERE CLOSELY WITH SENATOR
JACKSON AND JENNIFER BYRNE
PARTICULAR OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS -- INCLUDING I BELIEVE THE
CHAMBER SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT THE LANDMARK LEGISLATION
SO WE DEFINITELY DO NOT CAN
CONDONE PAY DISCRIMINATION.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL WE'VE TESTIFIED
ABOUT SIMILAR BILLS IN THE LAST.
FEW YEARS OLD I'LL KEEP OUR
COMMENTS BRIEF OUR OVERALL
CONCERN IS THAT -- THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IN THIS BILL CREATES
PERHAPS A FALSE IMPRESSION OF
WHICH DISCRIMINATION WHEN NINE
MAY IN FACT EXIST -- IT RELIES
ON JOB TITLES AND JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS.
NOT ALWAYS DISPARITIES UNLAWFUL
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE NON
DISCRIMINATORY REASONS FOR PAY
DISPARITIES.
BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
SAME JOB TITLES.
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE LEVELS YOU
CAN HAVE AN EMPLOYEE WHO'S GOT
THIRTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
WITH THE SAME JOB TITLES IN A
PLEA HAS SIX MONTHS OF
EXPERIENCE THEY OBVIOUSLY MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT PAY -- BUT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A VIOLATION OF
THE LAW BECAUSE THERE'S A
LEGITIMATE EXPLANATION FOR THE
DIFFERENCE -- AND WE DON'T THINK
THESE FACTORS WILL BE
SUFFICIENTLY CAPTURED IN THIS
PAID OUT AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT IT CREATES THE FALSE
IMPRESSION BUT THERE'S A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW AND IF THIS
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
TAKES ACTION ON THAT YES THE
EMPLOYER CAN.
BUT THAT IS THE TIME AND EXPENSE --
WHEN THERE'S NO VIOLATION OF THE
LAW?
BUT WE ALSO THINK -- YOU KNOW
WE'RE GETTING TO THE TAIL END OF
THE THE BACK AND FORTH OVER THE
FEDERAL EO ONE THERE WAS.
LITIGATION CHALLENGING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SCALING BACK TO
THE E. A ONE WORK REQUIREMENT.
IN MARCH THE THE COURT
OVERTURNED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS APPEALED.
THAT DECISION -- BUT THE EEOC IS
WEBSITE STATES THAT THE NOTICE
OF APPEAL DOES NOT POTS THE
COURT'S ORDER IN ANY WAY OR IN
ANY WAY ALTER THE EO ONE FILERS
OBLIGATIONS TO SUBMIT.
DATA TO BEGIN IN SEPTEMBER
THEY'RE ON TRACK TO BE UP
AGAINST COLLECTING PAID OUT OF
FOUR CALENDAR YEARS 220-172-2018.
SO WE HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS ON
IF THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
SEAMLESS WHAT WITH THE IMPENDING
EO ONE REQUIREMENT AND THESE
WERE RAISED IN THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS AS WELL.
WE THINK THERE SHOULD BE
CONSISTENCY AND SO WHILE THE
BILL PURPORTS TO PROVIDE AN
EMPLOYER CAN SIT SIMPLY SUBMIT
THAT FEDERAL EO ONE SATISFIES
REQUIREMENTS.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE AT THAT SAYS
IT HAS TO BE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR.
INFORMATION -- MAY BE
INTERPRETED TO MEAN THAT THE EO
ONE THE FEDERAL YEAR ONE IS NOT
ENOUGH THAT YOU HAVE TO SUBMIT
SOMETHING MORE.
WE'VE ALSO ASKED WE APPRECIATE
THE THE AUTHORS WORK TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S NOT A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST AND THIS
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED.
THE FEDERAL EO ONE REQUIREMENT
HAS SOME ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS
AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
FROM THE AGENCY WHO LEAKED THIS
INFORMATION IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE REYES THESE.
TWO AMENDMENTS.
AS A SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THEY
WERE NOT TAKEN IN THE SENATE WE
THINK AGAIN IF THIS IS GONNA BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL EO.
ONE THOSE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
WOULD HELP MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THIS IS IN FACT CONSISTENT WITH
THAT REQUIREMENT AND SO FOR
THESE THOSE REASONS WERE POSTED.
THANK YOU JUST TO JUST TO ADD
VERY BRIEFLY -- MISTER CHAIR.
FIRST ITEM IS THAT THE CENTER
JACKSON INDICATED THAT --
EMPLOYERS CARTE CANNOT COMBAT
WHAT THEY CAN'T SEE.
OBVIOUSLY IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS OF
THE EO ONE FORM.
BUSINESSES HAVE TO COMPILE THAT
DATA TO COMPLETE THE FORM SO
SUBMITTING THE SAME FORM.
A TO THE STATE UNDER THIS
MANDATE -- IT'S ALREADY BEEN
DONE AND IT'S ALREADY BEEN REYES
AND I THINK IS MISS STANDER
INDICATED.
THE IF YOU WILL PROVERBIAL GOOD
ACTORS ACTUALLY BEGAN COMPLYING
WITH SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
EIGHT IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED THAT BILL.
IN FACT IF YOU SAW MANY STORIES
IN THE MERCURY NEWS IN THE
CHRONICLE IN THE LA TIMES ABOUT
BUSINESSES PUBLICLY TRADED ONES
THAT WERE MAKING ANNOUNCEMENTS
HOW.
IF THEY COULDN'T JUSTIFY ANY PAY
DISPARITIES THEY WERE IN FACT --
RAISING THOSE SALARIES WHICH IS
OF COURSE IS A REQUIREMENT OF
THE LAW RATHER THAN LOWERING.
SO THE GOOD ACTORS HAVE BEEN IN
COMPLIANCE WITH SB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT IN THE AMENDMENTS TO LABOR
CODE SECTION ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
POINT.
FIVE SO I'M NOT SURE THAT IT IS
THE PANACEA BY COMPLETING THIS
FORM.
THE OTHER THING IS IF YOU IF
YOU'VE LOOKED AT THE SHORT E. E.
O. ONE FORM.
IT HAS CATEGORIES AND THEN IT
HAS -- PAY RANGES AND THEN MALE
FEMALE -- I'M NOT SURE WHAT SORT
OF TREND YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
FIND AND FRANKLY.
I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU WOULDN'T
IN FACT FIND DESPAIR PAY
DISPARITY AND I THINK IN MANY
INSTANCES YOU WOULD EXPECT IT.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT PROVISIONS
OF SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY EIGHT
WAS THE FACT THAT IT INCLUDED.
WHAT THE LAW TERMS AS BONTA
FIGHTER GOOD FAITH FACTORS IN
OTHER WORDS LAWFUL
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THOSE PAY
DISPARITIES?
NAMELY OF WHICH INCLUDES
EDUCATION TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE.
AS MR AT BEING.
NOTED YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE TWO
PEOPLE ONE WITH A COLLEGE DEGREE.
AND ONE WITH A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION.
OUR SOCIETY VALUES THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SO IN MOST
INSTANCES WE WOULD EXPECT THE
PERSON WITH A BACHELORS DEGREE
TO BE PAID MORE SIMILARLY
SOMEBODY WHO IS -- YOU KNOW IN
THE JOB FOR TEN YEARS VERSUS A
FIRST OR SECOND YEAR.
NOTHING NONE OF THOSE
JUSTIFICATIONS OR THOSE
EXPLANATIONS ARE THOSE BONAFIDE
FACTORS ARE ENUMERATED IN THOSE
IO FORMS HE ONE FORM SO I'M NOT
SURE.
WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW LEARN FROM THAT
RESPECTFULLY AND THE LAST ITEM
IS SENATOR JACKSON INDICATED?
HEY WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY PROBLEMS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL -- WITH ANY
DISCLOSURES WILL THAT IS BECAUSE
AT LEAST ONE REASON I BELIEVE IS
THAT THE FEDERAL LAWS MISTER I
THINK NOTED.
REQUIRES ANY VIOLATION TO BE
PROSECUTED AS A MISDEMEANOR AND
A THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WAS CITED
IN THE SENATE POLICY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND WE WOULD HOPE.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE WOULD SEE
FIT TO BRING THAT SO THAT THE
STATE LEVEL DOESN'T HAVE THE
SAME PROBLEMS THAT THE FED OR OR
PROBLEMS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH --
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHIP MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL WE HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE I WON WITH
THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT.
REGULARLY ABOUT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE PART OF THE
PREVIOUS A TESTIMONY.
SO UNTIL WE CAN REACH A
RESOLUTION ON THAT UNFORTUNATELY
WILL HAVE TO REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIDDING AND SOME
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
HI SEAN LUIS NATIONAL FEDERATION
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW
ON WESTERN GROWERS ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OR ANY MOTIONS ARE [inaudible]
B..
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
ON THE TABLE HERE -- IS ANY
FURTHER COMMENT ANY COMMENT FOOD
MEMBERS.
I CENTER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AGAIN -- I DO
THINK THAT THE GOALS ARE A LOT
ABOUT I THINK PUTTING THAT MERE
UP -- WHEN WE KNOW THESE
DISPARITIES EXIST OF ALL OUT AS
YOU INDICATED FIRST OF ALL BUT
THERE'S A LEGAL ACTION THE
COMPANIES CAN TAKE?
UP. TO TAKE APPROPRIATE MEASURES --
THEY CAN ALSO IDENTIFY PATTERNS
MAYBE THEY DON'T KNOW EXIST THAT
MAY NOT BE ILLEGAL BUT ALLOWS
THEM TO START TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR
AND AND THE THE AND ACTUALLY DO
PROACTIVE EFFORTS -- TO MOVE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND SO -- I
APPRECIATE -- YOUR THE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN TO CLEAR
DURING THE THE P. R. A. AND I
NEED -- FURTHER CONVERSATION
THAT THIS WILL IF IT PASSES GO
TO JUDICIARY SET UP AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE -- AND THEY'RE
WONDERFUL STAFF TO TO ME.
BUT FOR ANALYSIS AS TO THE
OPTIONS THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE --
AND OTHERWISE OF OF SUPPORTER
PREVIOUS EFFORTS I KNOW THAT THE
EFFORTS THAT.
SUMMER GONZALEZ AFFORD I PROPOSE
FOR THAT AS PER YOUR PREVIOUS
EFFORTS WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
SO -- WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
VERY BRIEFLY -- THE NOTION THAT
WERE THAT WERE GONNA SEE
LAWSUITS BECAUSE SOMEONE'S PAID
MORE THAN SOMEBODY ELSE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THAT'S THE FAIR PAY ACT
AND WILL YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY SHE
THAT IMPLEMENTED AND HOPEFULLY
SHE COMPANIES COMPLY WITHOUT THE
NEED FOR LITIGATION.
THIS IS TO LOOK AT THE LARGER
LEVEL ARE THERE PATTERNS OR IS
THEIR JOB SEGREGATION IF WE SEE
TWENTY MEN GETTING PAID HIGHER
SALARIES AND TWO WOMEN IN THAT
SAME CATEGORY.
IT MIGHT BEG THE QUESTION ARE AT
LEAST TWENTY MEN ARE THEY BETTER
EDUCATED DID THEY HAVE MORE
EXPERIENCE AND THOSE ARE ALL
DEFENSES IF THAT'S THE CASE.
I WOULD SUGGEST AND SUBMIT THAT
THE PROBLEM IS ONE OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED DISCRIMINATION
AND AS WAS POINTED OUT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I
CAN'T WAIT A HUNDRED AND ONE
YEARS FOR US TO GET A QUALITY I
CAN'T EVEN WAIT TILL -- TWENTY
FIFTY AND NEITHER SHOULD ANY THE
REST OF US WE HAVE PATTERNS OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED DISCRIMINATION
WHETHER INTENTIONAL OR NOT.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN -- OF BLOW THROUGH THAT --
CEILING WHETHER IT'S RACIALLY OR
GENDER BASED OR ETHNICALLY BASED
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE PAID AND
JUDGED ON THE QUALITY OF THEIR
WORK AND NOT ON THEIR GENDER NOT
ON THE RACE.
NOT ON THEIR ETHNICITY AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO HELP US DOING WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
MISS SUMMER GONZALEZ ACNE BY
SUMMER REVERSE ABOUT A CENTURY
OF CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CARILLO.
YEP.
YEP NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
ON CALL.
SO A SOVIET WILL KEEP THE BILL
ON COLONIES WERE MORE VOTE AND
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
MEMBERS OTHER COMMITTEES AND SO --
WILL WAIT FOR THEM. TO GIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
SET ASIDE A WINNER.
THIS IS THE SB.
ONE FORTY TWO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY -- OF THE CO PRESENTING
TIME IS INTERNET OKAY.
YOUR BRING IN THE LINES A LITTLE
ON THE MAN TALK ABOUT BREAST
FEEDING ON HIS OWN.
AS A BENEFICIARY OF
BREASTFEEDING I LITTLE INNER AND
OUTER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US -- ON
THE BILL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENT
THAT CLARIFIES THAT ARE ON D<c.cyan></c>
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION -- WILL BE
EXACTLY THE SAME AS WELL AS
FEDERAL LAW SO WERE CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW.
I'M SB ONE FORTY TWO INSURERS --
AN EASY TRANSITION FOR NEW
MOTHERS -- BACK TO WORK AND
MOVES US AWAY FROM FORCING NEW
MOTHERS -- TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
RETURNING TO WORK -- AND BREAST
FEEDING -- THEIR CHILD.
WE WANT -- WOMEN'S DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY RETURN TO
WORK -- AND NOT BE FORCED TO
DELAY -- IF THEY ARE ARE
BREASTFEEDING AND CONVERSELY WE
WANT WOMEN TO CHOOSE HOW LONG
THEY'VE BREAST FEED -- AND
RETURNING TO WORK SHOULD NOT BE
A BARRIER TO BREAST FEEDING.
ODD THERE ARE STILL TOO MANY
WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE WHO -- DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS -- TO DESCEND
AND PRIVATE AND CLEAN -- SPACE --
TO EXPRESS OF BREAST MILK.
AND AND TO BE ABLE TO WORK AT
THE SAME TIME -- AND SO THIS OF
LEGISLATION WILL SET SOME BASIC
STANDARDS WE KNOW THE CURRENT
LAW IS THAT YOU CAN'T FORCE
WOMEN TO EXPRESS MILK IN A
RESTAURANT THAT IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
BASELINE STANDARD BUT WE NEED TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT AND WE
HEAR TOO MANY STORIES OF WOMEN --
EXPRESSING MILK AND IN A BROOM
CLOSET OR OTHER UNACCEPTABLE
SPACE -- SO THE BILL WILL I
REQUIRE THAT -- EMPLOYER --
PROVIDE A PRIVATE SPACE WITH A
TABLE A CHAIR -- AN ELECTRIC
OUTLET.
AND NEARBY ARE REFRIGERATION AND
RUNNING WATER HI THIS IS NOT
SOME EXTRAORDINARY -- IMPOSITION
ON AN EMPLOYER -- IT IS PRETTY
BASIC IN ADDITION -- THE BILL
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY
TO EMPLOYERS IF AN EMPLOYER THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAVE WALLS FOR
PRIVATE ROOMS -- THEY CAN HAVE
TEMPORARY SPACES THAT DAY I SET
UP IN ADDITION IF YOU HAVE A
MULTI TENANT COMMERCIAL
SITUATION THEY CAN -- HAVE
SHARED SPACE AND WE DO HAVE THE
ON UNDO HARDSHIP -- PROVISION --
THAT -- CAN BE -- CLAIM BY --
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN.
FIFTY EMPLOYEES HI THIS BILL HAS
GONE THROUGH AN EVOLUTION WE
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY FOR THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF -- AND A MADE
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO ENSURE
FLEXIBILITY AND FOR EXAMPLE WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY -- AND WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE A AN OPEN DOOR --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AIBO AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PARTNER -- SOME
MEMBER GONZALEZ THANK YOU
SENATOR SAM THANK YOU AND I
THINK THE SENATOR DID A VERY
GOOD JOB OF EXPLAINING THE BILL
EXPLAINING I THINK THE AT THE
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF COMPROMISE
THAT HAS BEEN PUT INTO THIS BILL
TO MAKE IT WORKABLE FOR
EMPLOYERS -- IN IN TO A POINT
WHERE -- UNLESS WE'RE STILL
LEAVING A LOT OF WOMEN AND
PROTECTED BUT SOMETIMES WE HAVE
TO MAKE INCREMENTAL CHANGE --
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FEATURE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE TIME
PERIOD WE ALLOW OR EVEN COURAGE
WOMEN TO TAKE OFF WORK -- AFTER
HAVING A BABY DOESNOT MATCH UP
WITH THE TIME PERIOD THAT ANY
DOCTOR WILL TELL YOU IS HOW LONG
YOU SHOULD BE BREAST FEEDING --
ARE PROVIDING YOUR YOUR CHILD
WITH BREAST MILK IF POSSIBLE AND
SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING ON THE HEALTHIEST AT AND
AND MOST BENEFICIAL THING FOR
CHILDREN.
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE A SITUATION
BY WHICH A WOMAN CAN RETURN TO
WORK ON HER TIMELINE AND STILL
PROVIDE BREASTMILK -- I HAPPEN
TO HAVE.
HAD SOME OF THOSE EXPERIENCES
RETURNING TO SCHOOL AND THEN
LATER TO WORK ON ON DIFFERENT
CHILDREN -- WHILE I WAS STILL
BREAST FEEDING AND I'M HAVING.
BREAST FED IN BATHROOMS --
CLOSETS AT AT MY DESK WHERE
ANYONE CAN WALK AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT I IT IS YOU KNOW IT
TAKES A LOT IN THIS IS PROBABLY.
NOT FAIR TO SAY THE LEAST TO TO
ASK WOMEN -- TO DO THAT IN I
LITERALLY BROUGHT MY BABY AND
DEPRESSED FEET I WASN'T PUMPING --
PUMPING AS OF A FIRE -- MORE
INTENSE SITUATION A MOST MOST
WORKERS MUST WOMEN CAN'T JUST
BRING THEIR CHILD INTO BREAST
FEED OUT WORK AND SO -- PUMPING
IS THE ONLY POSSIBILITY -- THAT
SHE HOUSE AND SO TO DO THAT YOU
NEED PRIVACY YOU NEED AN OUTLET
YOU NEED.
A DESK OR A TABLE AND A CHAIR --
AND THOSE IN SOME PRIVACY AND
AND THAT'S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK
FOR OF COURSE WE DON'T WANT THAT
BREAST MILK TO GO BAD SO
REFRIGERATION AS WELL.
SO I THINK THIS IS COMMON SENSE
I THINK IT'S VERY LIMITED NOW IN
ITS APPLICATION AND IS ONE STEP
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY ACCOMMODATING WOMEN IN
THE WORKPLACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU OF THE END WITH THE
SAYS MONEY UP TO SIX MINUTES YOU
CAN DIVIDE IT UP AND YOU WAY
YOU'D LIKE.
THANK YOU CHUCK CHAIR KALRA
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING COALITION
COALITION IS PLEASED TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF SB.
ONE FOUR TWO AND WE WORK TO
PROMOTE PROTECT AND SUPPORT
BREASTFEEDING BECAUSE BREAST
MILK PROVIDES OPTIMAL NUTRITION
THAT BABIES NEED AND DESERVE.
AND BREAST FEEDING IMPACTS
MOTHERS LONG TERM HEALTH
DECREASING HER RISK FOR TYPE TWO
DIABETES.
OVARIAN AND BREAST CANCERS HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE AND HIGH
CHOLESTEROL AND THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT CALIFORNIA WOMEN.
WANT TO BREASTFEED 94% OF MOTHER
START OFF BREAST FEEDING IN THE
HOSPITAL BUT AT THREE MONTHS
POSTPARTUM ONLY 29%.
ARE FEEDING ONLY BREAST MILK TO
THEIR BABIES DESPITE THE URGING
OF ALL MAJOR MEDICAL AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION'S THAT
INFANTS ONLY BE FED BREASTMILK
FOR THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF LIFE
AN AT LEAST UP TO YEAR.
AS COMPLEMENTARY FOODS ARE
INTRODUCED.
A MAJOR REASON FOR THIS DRAMATIC
DECLINE IN BREAST FEEDING AT
THREE MONTHS POSTPARTUM IS
BECAUSE MOTHERS RETURNED TO WORK
TO ON SUPPORT OF WORKPLACES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOUND THAT MOTHERS.
HAVE -- THAT MOTHERS HAVE WITH
LOWER HOUSEHOLD INCOMES.
OR IF THEY'RE BLACK OR HISPANIC
ENTER THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS
NOT ENGLISH ARE LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE.
IN A LESS LIKELY TO HAVE A
SUPPORT OF WORKPLACE TO EXPRESS
MILK.
THE PROVISIONS IN SB ONE FORTY
TWO ARE CRITICAL TO IMPROVING.
BREASTFEEDING SUPPORT FOR
MOTHERS IN THE WORKPLACE
EXPRESSLY IN THIS TIME WHEN
MOTHERS WITH YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
THE FASTEST GROWING WORK FORCE
IN THE U. S..
IN THE WORKPLACE GREATLY IMPACTS
MOTHER'S ABILITY TO CONTINUE
BREASTFEEDING IMPRESS READING IS
AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
AND IT'S GOOD FOR BUSINESS.
WHEN EMPLOYERS SUPPORT THEIR
BREASTS BEING EMPLOYEES THAT
SUPPORT IMPROVES PRODUCTIVITY
BILLS EMPLOYEE MORALE INCREASES
EMPLOYEES LLOYD'S LOYALTY WHICH
HELPS RECRUIT AND RETAIN
EMPLOYEES?
IT ALSO DECREASES HEALTHCARE
COSTS IN ABSENTEEISM DUE TO
ILLNESS AND FOR THESE REASONS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU -- JULIE PARRISH
I'M A LAWYER AT LEGALLY THAT
WORK WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- ARE
WORKING FAMILY PROGRAM HERE'S
FROM THOUSANDS OF PARENTS A YEAR
STRUGGLING WITH THESE VERY
ISSUES AND I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY UNDERSCORE THAT.
NEW MOTHERS ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING SEGMENT OF THE WORK
FORCE WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THEM
EXPRESSED A DESIRE TO CONTINUE
TO GET THEIR BABIES BREAST MILK
WE KNOW THAT AFTER THEY WERE
DEFERRED TO WORK.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT -- AND OVER A
THIRD REPORT THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WORKPLACE SUPPORTS
NECESSARY SO THIS IS A CLEAR
PROBLEM THE THE HEALTH THE
EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
INTERVENTION WE HAVE.
AND I CAN'T UNDERSCORE NOT HELD
BASIC THESE PROVISIONS WERE
TALKING ABOUT OUR IT'S A CHAIR
AND A TABLE AND UP POLICIES SO
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO EVEN
ASK FOR THE ABILITY TO DO THAT --
FOR A LOT OF THE LOW WAGE
WORKERS THAT WE SPEAK WITH
APPROACHING A SUPERVISOR TO ASK
FOR LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS IS
A HUGE BARRIER AND FRANKLY ONE
OF THE THE GREATEST INNOVATIONS
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
THAT IT REQUIRES A POLICY THAT'S
TRANSLATED.
THAT'S DISTRIBUTED EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE PART OF THEIR WORKPLACE
RIGHTS PART OF WHAT A TRANSITION
BACK TO WORK LOOKS LIKE AND IT
GIVES EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIND A REALLY
COMMONSENSE SOLUTION TO WHATEVER --
CHALLENGES MAY BE PRESENT IN
THEIR PARTICULAR WORK FORCE OR
SITUATION -- THIS IS THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL THING THAT A PARENT
CAN DO FOR A CHILD IS YOU KNOW
PROVIDE THEM FOOD IT'S WHAT
KEEPS BABIES ALIVE -- AND IF WE
DON'T MAKE THESE MOST BASIC
IMPORTANT.
AND SIMPLE CHANGES TO WORKPLACE
REQUIREMENTS WE ARE GOING TO
EITHER EXCLUDE WOMEN AND NEW
MOTHERS FROM THE WORK FORCE OR
FORCE THEM. TO STOP BREAST
FEEDING THEIR BABIES BEFORE
THEY'RE READY TO DO SO AND NO
ONE'S EMPLOYER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION FOR THEM.
THANK YOU.
OF ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN THE
STAR CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN WAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
KATHERINE -- GONE ON BEHALF OF
FIRST OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KAREN FARLEY CALIFORNIA WITH
ASSOCIATION PRO CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
SHE WAS WITH RALLY ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN FOR
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GIVE.
PAUL YOU ARE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSOR THE BILL THANK.
YOU.
I'M NOT ABOUT OTHER WITH CREW
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE HìNH SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DANIEL KEY ACLU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND AMERICAN COLLEGE
OBGYN STRYCHNINE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUST BIRTH LOW ESTRIN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND A MOM WHO
BREAST FED AT WORK.
IT'S WHAT THANK YOU.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE ONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BECOME HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- AND AS A
MYTH MAIL OPPOSING THIS BILL IN
FULL.
WITH A LOT OF KIDS IT GIVES ALL
THIS IS WITH A LOT OF AND IF IT
I DO FOR THE RECORD.
I'M A FATHER OF SEVEN CHILDREN
ALL OF ALL OF WHOM WERE
EXCLUSIVELY BREASTFED FOR LONGER
THAN TWELVE MONTHS SO I'M A BIG
FAN OF FEEDING AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IS NOT OPPOSED TO LACKS
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVEL LAST YEAR
ON HER AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
IT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ARE SOME OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL.
WHICH WE DO THINK WE'LL BE
BURDENSOME FORMER EMPLOYERS AND
LEAD TO INCREASED LITIGATION.
WE APPRECIATE AUTHORS -- EFFORTS
ON THIS BILL IS DIALOGUE LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR AND
MAINTENANCE THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THUS FAR BUT WE DO HAVE
REMAINING CONCERNS AND I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THOSE.
NUMBER ONE THE BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS I'M SO WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEW BUILDING
CODE REQUIREMENTS CONTAINED IN
THIS BILL.
AND ALL ALTHOUGH THE AUTHOR
ELIMINATED THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL NOW SAYS
THE SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE IS
THE STARTING POINT WHICH WE
THINK IS ESSENTIALLY THE SAME --
AND BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE IN
SAN FRANCISCO EMPLOYERS -- COSTS
FOR THOSE BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN BETWEEN
THIRTY AND A HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WELL IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE AT
ORDINANCES BEEN.
IN EFFECT -- WE WOULD KNOW
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED SB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN LAST YEAR WHICH DID
NOT CONTAIN THE BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS SO WE'VE ASKED FOR
THE BUILDING CODE PROVISIONS TO
BE DELETED FROM THIS BILL.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL DUPLICATES -- LIABILITY FOR
RETALIATION THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT ALREADY
REGULATES DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION ISSUES INVOLVING.
A LACTATION ACCOMMODATION IN THE
FIFA REMEDIES INCLUDE
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF PUNITIVE DAMAGES
ATTORNEY'S FEES SO WE DON'T
REALLY SEE THE NEED TO
INCORPORATE.
RETALIATION AND DISCRIMINATION
PROVISIONS INTO THE LABOR CODE.
ANYTIME YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
CODES IN TWO DIFFERENT AGENCIES --
ENFORCING IN INTERPRETING
OVERLAPPING PROVISIONS OF THE
LAW WE THINK THAT CAN LEAD TO
CONFUSION -- AN INCONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT AND AGAIN WE DO HAVE
INCREASED THE CONCERNS ABOUT
INCREASED LITIGATION COSTS
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THESE
PRESCRIPTIVE AND DETAILED
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN THE LABOR
CODE AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TAKING OUT THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION.
BUT IT'S THE LABOR CODE IT'S
STILL SUBJECT TO PAGA FOR ANY
VIOLATION PARK HAS NO HARM
REQUIREMENT YOU CAN BE A MINOR
TECHNICAL VIOLATION OF ANY THESE
APARTMENTS AND IT'S SUBJECT TO A
POPULAR VACATION.
SO WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE INCREASED
LITIGATION HERE.
AND THE LAST POINT I WANTED TO
RAISE IS WITH RESPECT TO THE
PROVISION THAT ADDS THE
LACTATION BREAKS TO LABOR CODE
SECTION TWO TO SIX POINT.
SEVEN WHICH IS THE REMEDY OF ONE
HOUR PAY FOR NOT PROVIDING MEAL
AND REST PERIODS TWO EMPLOYEES
AND SO MEAL RECIPES ARE --
EASIER FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO
IMPLEMENT AND POLICE SAID
MONITOR BECAUSE THEY'RE BASED ON
VERY FINITE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
LAW THE MEAL PERIOD HAS TO BE
PROVIDED BEFORE THE END OF THE
FIFTH HOUR OF WORK.
REST PERIODS HAVE TO BE PROVIDED
EVERY FOUR HOURS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THOSE FOR OUR CHEFS.
LACTATION THE COMBINATION BREAKS
BY NATURE ARE MORE SUBJECTIVE
EVERY EMPLOYEE IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT EVERYBODY EMPLOYEES
CAN HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS MORE
FREQUENCY OF BREAKS.
SO FOR THAT REASON THAT IT'S
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE EMPLOYER
TO MONITOR AND POLICE THAT THE
EMPLOYEE IS TAKING THOSE BREAKS
AT THE GIVEN TIME THAT THEY NEED.
AND SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
IMPOSING THE HARSH PENALTY OF
LABOR CO TWO TO SIX POINT SEVEN
DOESN'T MESH WITH.
THAT SUBJECTIVE NATURE OF THESE
TYPE OF BREAKS AND SO WE'VE
ASKED THAT THE PROVISIONS ADDING.
LACTATION BREAKS THE LABOR CODE
SECTION TWO TO SIX POINT SEVEN
BE DELETED FROM THE BILL -- SO
WE'VE SUBMITTED PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO AUTHORS OFFICE ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STAFF BUT FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE ALSO POSE
FOR THE REASONS THAT WERE
OUTLINED TO BY THE CHAMBER BUT
ALSO FOR A PARTICULAR REASON
RELATED TO MANUFACTURING.
SO WE UNDERSTAND -- EAT THE NEED
TO TRY.
TO CONFORME THIS BILL -- TO THE
FEDERAL LAW RELATED TO THE UNDUE
HARDSHIP AND WHILE WE DIDN'T
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
RELATED TO THAT PROVISION.
WE THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT RELATED TO
MANUFACTURING IT'S NOT REALLY
BASS THE HARDSHIP IS NOT REALLY
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
BUT REALLY ON THE CHARACTERISTIC
OF THE INDUSTRIAL FACILITY.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU HAVE
FIVE EMPLOYEES IN THAT FACILITY
OR YOU HAVE A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A PLACE OTHER
THAN THE BATHROOM THAT IS CLOSED
OFF FOR PRIVACY. FOR SAFETY FOR
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
EXPOSED TO THE OUTPUT OF THE
MANUFACTURING PRACTICE THEN YOU
CANNOT PROVIDE.
ACCORDING TO THE THE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL AND YOU WOULD NEED
TO PROVIDE THAT SPACE THAT
PROVIDES THAT PRIVACY AND
SECURITY AND AND ELIMINATION FOR
EXPOSE OR TWO THAT THOSE BY
PRODUCTS.
EVEN A TEMPORARY STRUCTURE MAY
NOT WORK IF YOU EVER SEEN THESE
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES THEY COULD
BE FILLED THE WHOLE FACILITY
COULD BE FILLED WITH INDUSTRIAL
EQUIPMENT AND THERE JUST ISN'T A
PLACE TO PUT A TEMPORARY.
STRUCTURE SO THAT'S WHY WE WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER Là M<c.cyan> LAST YEAR AND</c>
WORK ON A HARDSHIP EXEMPTION
THAT TOOK INTO THE CONSIDERATION.
THE CHARACTERISTIC OF THE
FACILITY IN ADDITION TO THAT TO
ADDRESS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CONCERNED THAT ALL EMPLOYERS
COULD NOW SELL CERTIFY IF YOU
WILL THAT THEY HAD A HARDSHIP
AND THEREFORE COULD.
COME UNDER THIS EXEMPTION SHE
PUT LANGUAGE IN THERE SO THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO BASICALLY
CERTIFIED TO THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THE HARDSHIP EXISTED SO WAS A
LITTLE YOU KNOW SOMETHING ON THE
BACK IN TO MAKE SURE.
THAT EMPLOYERS JUST WEREN'T
CLAIMING OUT WHEN IT WASN'T
POSSIBLE WE THINK THAT PROVIDES --
ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS OF THAT
ARTHUR BUT ALSO PARTICULARLY THE
CONCERNS OF THIS COMMITTEE
RELATED TO THAT HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY
ASKING IS FOR THE HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION TO MIRROR WHAT'S IN
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IF THIS BILL DID BE COME
LAW IT WOULD PROVIDE MORE
PROTECTIONS TO EMPLOYEES AND BY
DOING THAT THE CALIFORNIA LAW
WOULD GOVERN.
AND SO NOW WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT A
CALIFORNIA LAW RELATED TO THAT
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION WOULD BE
ROLLED BACK AND FROM THE
MANUFACTURER'S PERSPECTIVE THAT
BE ROLLING BACK THE FAX ABILITY
THAT WE NEED. FOR OUR FACILITIES
WHEN THEY CANNOT ACCOMMODATE THE
INCLUSION OF A PERMANENT OR
TEMPORARY LACTATION SPACE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS AND THE REASONS
PREVIOUS STATED WE ARE POST
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M AT THE ANY OF THE TIMES UP
FOR COMMENTARY BUT OR FROM --
FOR WITNESSES BUT WE ARE.
HAPPY TO OPEN UP TO ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION NAME TITLE AND THE
POSITION MATTHEW HARPER THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION I WAS GOING TO WELL
YOU WITH BUILDING CODE TALK.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO THERE.
YEAH YOU CAN DO ABOUT THE BMP
COMMITTEE ABOUT THAT OKAY.
THANK YOU THE APPRECIATE IT.
HI KATIE HANSEN RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
JOHN LEWS NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF IN A BUSINESS FIRMS AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POSTING.
THANK YOU AND THAT I WILL MAKE
NOTE THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN.
DISCUSSED WITH OUR WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF WOULD ACTION BE
TAKEN UP IN BE IN P..
AND SO FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
FEEDBACK ON SOME OF THE FOR THE
FEDERAL CONFORMITY AND OTHER
ISSUES THERE'S STILL AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WOULD BE
IN PEACE STAFF -- AND FOR THE
DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS SOME OF THOSE DETAILS -- ANY
COMMENT [inaudible]
OR QUESTIONS OR AND I WANT THANK
YOU BOTH FOR BRINGING THIS UP --
I I I I HEAR TO CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION IN.
AND THE CHAMBER BUT I I ALSO AS
AN AUTHOR.
OF A BILL. TO ALLOW --
INCARCERATED WOMEN TO BREAST
FEED WHILE THEY'RE IN JAIL AND
IF YOU THINK IT'S DIFFICULT. FOR
YOU TO DO THAT AND PROBABLY IS A
FUTURE AUTHOR OF HAVING WOMEN
WHO ARE IN PRISON.
BEING ABLE TO TO BREAST FEED YOU
CAN ALSO ME UNDERSTAND HOW
DIFFICULT EVEN THAT WOULD BE --
I'M SURE WE COULD MEET THIS
THRESHOLD WHICH I THINK IS THAT
MUCH LOWER -- I'M A DIFFICULT
DIFFICULTY LEVEL.
CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT AND AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I I DON'T KNOW IF
I CAN STILL BE AT IS A CO AUTHOR
I. SHOULD.
RECALL THROUGH ON ALL OF THESE
PRESS MEETING BILLS -- BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL.
PART OF WHO WE SHOULD BE.
AS AS A COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU RAPID IDEA.
THE END RESULT IN MOTION.
SOME OF THE SECOND.
WAY IS THE SECOND.
THANK YOU -- THE OTHER COMMENT.
AND IF NOT -- I'D ALSO I THOUGHT.
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR I'M NOT AT THIS POINT I I
KNOW THAT -- WE SEE THE WORLD WE
SEE THE THE WAY THAT WE SEE IT
AND SOMETIMES AS MEN WE DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE THE CHALLENGE
THAT WOMEN -- THAT'S A FACE AND
A ONE THOUSAND SOUNDS A CITY
COUNCIL -- THERE WAS.
A MEETING THAT WE HAD AND AFTER
THE MEETING A WOMAN ASKED WHERE
CAN I GO TO PUMP.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY FACILITY IS
HOW THE CITY HALL AND SO WE YOU
LET HER USE NOW OFFICE CLOSE THE
BLINDS LOCKED THE DOOR SO SHE
CAN USE MY OFFICE BUT THAT'S THE
NEXT YEAR IS WHEN I PUT FORWARD.
LOCAL ORDINANCE REQUIRE INNER
CITY HALL ARCHES COMPANIES IN
OUR PARK AND ZOO AND ON FROM
THERE BUT IT WAS UNTIL THAT
MOMENT IN TIME.
I DIDN'T SEE.
AND SO IT ALLOWED ME TO SEE --
THE NEED FOR IT AND SO I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO BE YEAR
AND SUPPORT THIS EFFORT AS WE
NEED TO DO MORE.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A OF A A
GREAT STEP AND I THINK THEY'LL
BE MORE TO FOLLOW AS WE'VE HEARD
FROM A SUMMER GONZALEZ AND AS IN
REGIONS WHERE BUT BUT CENTER WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD AND SO I
SUPPORT IT.
AND IT DOES HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION -- DO PASS A TO
BUT BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE WHERE SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND AND AND DETAILS
ON THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP -- AND
UP IS LIKE TO CLOSE UNDER.
SPOKE WITH WHEN I WROTE THANK
YOU.
MADAM SECTOR OF CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
MOTION IS THE PASSED TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING CARILLO.
YEAH.
THE OTHER AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US THREE
OF US I THE LIST AND THAT DOES --
THAT DOES PASS WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN -- SO THANK YOU CENTER.
UNLESS YOU HAVE SENATORS STERN.
SB.
SEVEN THIRTY I'LL BE ALSO HAVE A
GUEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IN A MATCH I KNOW.
THIS IS THE NEW TREND THE MAIN
AUTHOR.
DOESN'T HAVE MUCH STATURE
[inaudible]
WELL.
THE MOTION ARE VICE CHAIRS ARE
SECOND.
SECOND FOR SUMMER GONZALEZ SAID
SENATOR STERN YES YES YOU'RE
VERY NICE WELCOME RIGHT YES I'LL
BE BRIEF AND I DON'T TAKE YEAH
I'LL TAKE YES FOR AN ANSWER.
AND SHE IN SHORT.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES --
BRIEF BUT THOROUGH ANALYSIS --
WE THINK IS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
TO JUMPSTART A CRITICAL
CONVERSATION IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT --
WHAT TAKEN AN EQUITY STAKE IN
FUTURE OUTCOMES -- COULD LOOK
LIKE WHEN YOU HAVE GOOGLE
PUTTING FORTH A BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE HOUSING IN SAN JOSE --
THAN SAN JOSE RESPONDING -- BY
TALKING ABOUT LABOR STANDARDS I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S A HEALTHY
KIND OF EVOLUTION -- WHERE WE
SEE BOTH FOLKS WHO ARE --
DRIVING THE ECONOMY BUT ALSO
POTENTIALLY DISPLACING WORKERS
ARE IMPACTING HOUSING PRICES HOW
TODAY'S OR TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND EQUITABLE WAY I WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IMPACTS ON DEMOCRACY FOR
INSTANCE AND YOU KNOW.
FACEBOOK IS A IS A SERIOUS
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY IN SOME
REGARDS AND YET WE ALL USE
FACEBOOK TO REACH OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND FIND WAYS TO
GET THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY GET OUR
MESSAGE OUT SO.
WRESTLING WITH THOSE ISSUES IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET AHEAD OF
AND FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I DO APPRECIATE -- MY CO
AUTHOR HERE FROM DOWN SOUTH.
WHO JUST GIVE ME A THUMBS UP?
THANK YOU CENTER IS A MEMBER.
I THINK IF AS WE ARE
TECHNOLOGIES CHANGING SO MUCH OF
WHAT WE DO AND HOW WE DO IT.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE AS A STATE.
DON'T JUST LET THE SIGNAL OUT
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES HAPPEN --
BUT THAT WE ARE PLENTIFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL.
ABOUT AND DESPAIR TECHNOLOGY
FUTURE AND I THINK THAT'S THE
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL AND NAY.
I COMMISSION ON TECH EQUITY WILL
ENSURE THAT.
AS WE TAKE ADVANTAGES OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT.
NO ONE IN CALIFORNIA GETS LEFT
BEHIND.
THANK YOU.
OF ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
UP SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU SO MUCH BRING THIS FOR
I DO THINK IN MANY WAYS THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN FORCED UPON US
IT'S UP TO US TO DECIDE HOW TO
RESPOND AND SO -- I THINK THIS
IS A DEFINITELY A POSITIVE STEP.
AND WE DO HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION -- TO PASS TO THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE.
ANY CLOSING THOUGHTS RESPECT
THEIR TRAVEL THANK YOU.
MADAM SECTOR TO CALL WILL PLEASE.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO YEP.
HI GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT.
MY BODY GUARD.
I DON'T KNOW I I AM -- SET
SENATOR CABALLERO RUNNING IS
SOLO -- IS A SOLO.
WELL I SOME SAY THEY KNOW
EXACTLY.
THESE THESE GUYS NEED ALL THE
HELP THEY CAN GET I GUESS --
CENTER AND CABALLERO -- WE HAVE
SB TWENTY FIVE AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHENEVER AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR -- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
SB TWENTY FIVE WHICH CREATES AN
INCENTIVE FOR GREEN SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT FOR CRITICAL HOUSING
STATEWIDE.
AND FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITY ZONES --
THOSE OF YOU THAT THANK YOU
THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW ME AND MY
BACKGROUND UNDERSTAND SB.
TWENTY FIVE I STARTED OFF
WORKING AS AN ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING WORKING FAMILIES IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY IN PARTICULAR
FARMWORKERS AND FOR THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS -- I'VE WORKED AS
AN A SELECTED LOCAL FOCUSING ON
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SUCCESS FOR THOSE THAT ARE
SYSTEMATICALLY PRECLUDED FROM
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE OF
POVERTY -- I HAVE WORKED TO
BUILD RESILIENCY AND ARE POOREST
COMMUNITIES BY CHANGING THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH PEOPLE LIVE
WORK AND PLAY.
SO FOR AS ELECTED OFFICIALS I
KNOW THAT YOU HERE REGULARLY
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT
PERVASIVE POVERTY AND HARDSHIP
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
POVERTY THAT RESULTS FROM THE
LACK OF GOOD PAYING JOBS.
POVERTY THAT TAKES AWAY AMBITION
AND HOPE AND POVERTY THAT LEADS
TO RESIGNATION THAT THINGS HAVE
NO CHANCE TO IMPROVE.
SB TWENTY FIVE IS A MODEST
ATTEMPT TO JOIN FORCES WITH THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT DESIGNED TO
FUNNEL AN ESTIMATED SIX TRILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM CAPITAL GAINS EARNINGS INTO
AMERICA'S POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS
SB TWENTY FIVE ATTACKS POVERTY
IN THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE DESIGNATED OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING MARKET CONDITIONS
FOR PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAPITAL
TO REACH COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY CHRONIC POVERTY.
IT SETS THE HIGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS FOR
QUALITY PROJECTS AND CUT IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRING THAT ALL
CONSTRUCTION BEACON SYSTEM WITH
LOCAL GENERAL PLANT ZONING CODES.
AND REQUIRES LED L. E. D. LEAD
CERTAIN GOLD CERTIFICATION ZERO
NET EMISSIONS AND ZERO NET GHG.
IT PROTECTS COMMUNITY
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
BY REQUIRING A UP TO SEVENTY
PART 5% OF THE TOTAL SQUARE
FOOTAGE IN MIXED USE.
BE DEDICATED TO HOUSING WITH A
MINIMUM OF 40% OF THE UNITS
BEING AFFORDABLE WITH A THIRTY
YEAR AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS.
IT REQUIRES SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKERS FOR ALL HOUSING PROJECTS
GREATER THAN TWENTY FIVE UNITS
AND CREATES NEW WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN GREEN BUILDING
TRADES.
WHICH IS A SKILL SET THAT THE
STATE DESPERATELY NEEDS.
REQUIRES PREVAILING WAGES FOR
PROJECTS ABOVE TWENTY FIVE UNITS
AND IT REQUIRES THAT ALL
PROJECTS GO THROUGH THE EXACT
DECISIONS REGARDING SEEK BUT
THAT SET FOR TO FOURTH TODAY.
SO IT IS NOT A SEQUEL EXCEPTION
AND I REPEAT THAT IT'S NOT AN
EXEMPTION.
IT DOES ONE THING ONLY IT GIVES
PROJECTS AN OPPORTUNITY ZONES
AND HOUSING PROJECTS FINANCED
WITH TAX PAYERS MONEY.
CERTAINTY THAT THE PROJECT FUNDS
AND THE PROJECT WILL NOT BE
UNDULY BURDENED BY NAME BE
LITIGATION.
IT DOES THIS BY SIMPLY REQUIRING
THE COURTS TO SEEK TO REACH A
FINAL DISPOSITION WITHIN TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAYS.
IF FEASIBLE THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
THE OFFRAMP -- IT WILL
DISCOURAGE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
pTHEY ARE CHALLENGING PROJECTS
THAT ARE HAVE ALREADY MET AN
INCREDIBLY HIGH PUBLIC INTEREST
STANDARD AND THAT THE SUITS WILL
BE RISK RESOLVED IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHICH
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
INVESTMENT IN IN -- IN THESE
PROJECTS -- IT CREATES A
MULTIPLIER EFFECT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALREADY MADE --
DISCUSSED THAT AND THEY'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT -- MAKING THE
AYE BACK.
SPUR OPPORTUNITIES OWN
INVESTMENT -- DEVELOPMENT AND
THEY WANT TO CREATE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNED IN ADDITION
TO HOUSING.
SO IT AMPLIFIES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTEREST IN
OPPORTUNITY SOUNDS.
SO -- I'LL THAT THIS BILL IS
COMMITTED TO TACKLING TACTIC
DECADES OF INSUFFERABLE POVERTY
FOR THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE CENSUS TRACKS THAT
ARE CALIFORNIA'S POOREST.
HOUSING AND JOB FOR COMMUNITIES
AND IT DOES THIS BE FOR THAT.
THAT FEDERAL BILL SUNSET WELL
THIS HAS A FIVE YEAR SUNSET IT
THAT MATCHES THE SUNSET THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS HAS
SET SO.
PART OF THE KEY HERE IS MATCHING
UP THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR PRIVATE FUNDS WITH
OUR OWN -- WITH OUR OWN
EXPEDITED LITIGATION PROCESS SO
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YOU HVE UP TO SIX
MINUTES TO BUY IT ANYWAY YOU'D
LIKE.
HI FOR ME WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
THAT SPONSOR THE BELL.
AND AT SEQUENT DEFINITELY WERE
SUPPORT OF A C. QUIET AND IT HAS
A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT HOWEVER IT HAS
BECOME A TOOL THAT IS BEEN USED
AND ABUSED TO DISCOURAGE AND
DELAY HOUSING PRODUCTION
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA
AN EXAMPLE IN REDWOOD CITY.
WITH A TWENTY UNIT PROJECT I'M
FOR HABITAT HOMEOWNER SERVING
5280% AVERAGE MEDIAN INCOME THEY
WERE TO ACTUALLY DELAYED FOR
SIXTEEN MONTHS TO THE LITIGATION
FORTUNATELY THE PROJECT WAS ABLE
TO GO FORWARD AND LIKE SEVERAL
OTHER PROJECTS IN THE REGION
THAT WERE DELAYED AND THREATENED
BY THE SAME LET AGAINST.
AND THOSE PROJECTS WERE ABLE TO
GO FORWARD -- SO HOPEFULLY THAT
THIS AGAIN WAS JUST STREAMLINING
OF THE JUDICIAL REVIEW AND DOES
NOT EXEMPT ANY OTHER PROJECTS
FROM SEA QUEST AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR IPHONE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AS EARLY AS A BEHALF OF STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL A WE WANNA THANK CENTER
COUPLE YET -- FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE IMPORTANT LABOR
STANDARDS THAT ARE ATTACHED TO
THIS INVESTMENT.
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHERE
PERHAPS THERE IS LACK OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AS THE STATE LOOKS TO INVEST IN
HOUSING -- WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
A CRISIS OUT THERE WE KNOW THAT
ALL FORMS OF INCOME OF
ELIGIBILITY SHOULD BE -- BUILT
FOR IN TERMS OF PRODUCTION FROM
THE LOWEST TO THE MIDDLE TO HIGH --
BUT WE ARE FOCUSED NECESSARILY
HERE WITH THIS LEGISLATION ON
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT PROVISIONS
THAT ALLOW 440% TO BE ALLOCATED
FOR THE A A MINE. FOR YOU KNOW
80% EIGHTY AND MY AND BELOW IS
VERY IMPORTANT IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT THAT IS VERY -- LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THAT WILL BE BE
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THAT -- IN
THAT I THINK ALSO DEALS WITH THE
ISSUE OF GENTRIFICATION WHERE
YOU HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO PRODUCE HOUSING
THAT -- ACTUALLY WILL DIVERSIFY
THE COMMUNITIES BUT NOT ALSO
VOWED KICK PEOPLE OUT NINE I
MYSELF LIVED IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'VE SEEN THE IMPACTS AND
GENTRIFICATION -- IF THERE WERE
HIGHER IN COMMAND OF LEVELS I
THINK THAT WOULD BE BETTER
SUITED FOR IN THE COMMUNITY I
GREW UP IN THE MISSION DISTRICT
BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE -- THE IMPORTANT
LABOR PROTECTIONS ARE ENSURE
THAT THE INVESTMENT THAT IS
BEING MADE AND AS A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT LEAVE THE
WORKERS THAT ARE BUILDING THE
ASSETS BEHIND.
RIGHT WE KNOW THAT CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM
LOW WAGES IN A NON UNIONIZED
ENVIRONMENT.
WHAT WE WANT TO JUST TRY TO DO
HERE IS INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF
THE PREVAILING WAGE TO LIFT UP
EVEN WHEN THERE'S A NON UNION
CONTRACTOR ON THE JOB?
THAT THOSE NONUNION CONTRACTORS
SO THAT THAT THAT DOES NOT.
FURTHER CREATE MORE OF A NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
UP ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON WE HAVE
A WEST FIELD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OF IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICHARD MARX AND ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION BUT
WE DO APPLY THE AUTHORS EFFORT
TO INCENTIVIZE OF THIS TYPE OF
CONSTRUCTION AND OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS.
A BUT WE ARE TROUBLED BY OF WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS A OF A TREND IN
LEGISLATION LIKE SB.
FIFTY FIVE THAT WE THINK IS IS
VERY CONTRARY TO PUBLIC POLICY
AND ACTUALLY.
IS SOMETHING THAT A WERE
SURPRISED THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD AGREE WITH AND THAT IS THE
PROVISION THAT BARS.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER FROM
ENFORCING WAGE AND HOUR RULES ON
CERTAIN PROJECTS THAT ARE
COVERED BY A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
EXACERBATING THIS IS A SIMILAR
WAIVER THAT ELIMINATES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT CONTRACTORS
KEEP IN SUBMIT CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORDS TO VERIFY THAT THE WAGES
ARE BEING PAID AND THE BENEFITS
ARE BEING PAID.
IF THIS TREND CONTINUES CAN WE
EXPECT TO SEE SIMILAR PROVISIONS
THAT SAYS THAT CALLOW SURE
CANNOT ENFORCE HEALTH AND SAFETY
RULES THAT OF THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
ADMINISTRATION.
COULD NOT ENFORCE THESE
PROVISIONS IF THERE'S A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THIS LANGUAGE SHOULD BE REMOVED.
THE WORKERS DESERVE THE
PROTECTION.
OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER AND
THE ONLY WAY TO VERIFY THAT THE
ONLY WAY TO HAVE A RECORD TO
VERIFY THAT WAGES AND BENEFITS
ARE BEING PAID.
IS D. COLLECTION AND THE
SUBMISSION OF CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORDS.
WITHOUT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SYDNEY FONG I'M A FELLOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
A COALITION REPRESENTING TWENTY
THOUSAND ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN
LATINO X. AFRICAN AMERICAN LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS WHO HAVE LONG
INJURED -- POLLUTION BURDENS
ACROSS THE STATE -- WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AUTHORS AND
STATED INTENTIONS BEHIND THE
BILL WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE SB
TWENTY FIVE I'M HOWEVER WE'RE
CURRENTLY AND CONVERSATIONS --
WEST -- AUTHORS OFFICE TO SEE IF
WE CAN GET ALL OF OUR CONCERNS
ADDRESSED -- FOR INSTANCE --
BOTHER PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS ARE VERY
COMMENDABLE -- WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL WOULD INCENTIVIZE
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD PROJECTS
THAT WOULD NOT ACTUALLY SERVE
LOCAL LOW INCOME RESIDENTS WOULD
NOT GIVE THEM GOOD JOBS AND
COULD LEAD TO GREATER.
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS I'M A WE
HAVE FOUND LUXURY HOTELS AND
OFFICE BUILDINGS AND FOR TECH
WORKERS COULD BE SOME.
THESE OWNS AND FUNDS -- WHICH
COULD LEAD TO GREATER
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
OF LONG TIME RESIDENTS NUMBER
CONCERNS THAT -- THERE ARE NO
LOCAL HIGHER PROVISIONS --
INCLUDED IN THE BILL --
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN SAY HOW AND
GROUPS SUCH AS STRATEGIC
ALLIANCE FOR JUST ECONOMIES IN
SOUTH LA -- AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT JOBS GO TOO LONG
LONG TIME LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
THROUGH LOCAL HIGHER PROVISIONS.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO PROMOTE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES FOR
DEVELOPERS AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
NEEDS OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WE OF
COURSE HAVE ADDITIONAL AT
CONCERNS RELATED TO SEE CA AN
EXPEDITED TO JUDICIAL REVIEW --
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT YOU CAN
SHARE IN THE FUTURE IS NEEDED
AND FOR SAY HI OR COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN AT THE FRONT LINES OF
POVERTY AND POLLUTION AND SEE
WHAT IS ONE OF THE LAST TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY AIR LAND AND WATER.
AS A WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO
REQUEST A COMMITMENT I'M FROM
THE AUTHORS I TO HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER MEETING PRIOR TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS OUR
SHARED GOALS -- OF REGARDING
PREVAILING WAGE AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO NOT HARM AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
EXPANDED X. VETTING JUDICIAL
REVIEW OF SEE C<c.cyan> ENVIRONMENT</c>
TO REVIEW DOCUMENTS INCLUDING
ENVIRONMENT.
AT NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS
DETERMINATIONS OF EXEMPTIONS AND
ENVIRONMENT IMPACT REPORTS OF
FOR SUCH A BROAD RANGE OF
PRODUCTS WOULD UNDERMINE THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOUNDATION A LOT WHICH
IS SEE WHAT.
THE STATED PURPOSE OF THE BILL
IS TO ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT DOES HAVE
VERY CLEAR CLIMB IMPACTS.
BUT YET THE PROJECTS FUNDED
THROUGH THE OPPORTUNITIES OWN
FUNDS AREN'T LIMITED TO THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS -- WHICH WOULD
QUALIFY AS LONG AS ARE PARTIALLY
FUNDED BY THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ON
FUNDS AND WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR OTHER TYPES OF
DEVELOPMENT IN -- IDENTIFIED
OPPORTUNITIES OUNCE BUT
STREAMLINING THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
IN PUBLIC PARTICIPATION FOR
THESE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE MORE THAN LIKELY ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH HISTORIC AIR
WATER AND SOIL POLLUTION.
WOULD POTENTIALLY PUT THEM AT
EVEN GREATER DISADVANTAGE -- IN
TERMS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THAT THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
WILL BE EXPERIENCING -- I WOULD
ALSO JUST POINT OUT THAT THERE
ARE ALREADY NUMEROUS
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS ALREADY
AVAILABLE AND THIS YOU CAN SEE
WHAT APPLICABLE TO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS INCLUDING
STREAMLINING RELATE RELATED TO
MASTER IN FOCUS ER'S.
INFILL RESIDENTIAL MIXED USE AND
TRANSIT PERHAPS PARITY PROJECTS
AN EXEMPTION OR IT FOR TRANSIT
A PARTY PROJECTS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUSLY
ADOPTED SPECIFIC PLANS.
AND THE RELEVANT REGIONAL
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
AND EXPANSION OF IT EIGHT OF THE
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR INFO
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING BY
INCREASING THE ALLOWABLE
PERCENTAGE OF NEIGHBORHOOD
SERVING COMMERCIAL USES WITHIN A
PROJECT -- SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE EXISTING -- CHILLING VISIONS
THAT THEY'RE IN LAW CURRENTLY
AND I WOULD ALSO JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE BILL DOES PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL STREAMLINING FOR SEA
QUEST.
CHALLENGES FOR A TOTAL OF TWELVE
PUBLIC FUNDS -- SO MUCH
OPPORTUNITIES AND FUNDS BUT
ELEVEN OTHERS -- AND SO FORTH
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL THE BILL IN ORIGIN OF A
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT A PUSH TO
THE PREMISE OF THE BILL BUT TO
THE PROVISIONS THAT --
DISADVANTAGE OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE
NON UNION CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
THANK YOU.
I ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE END OF ASK IS --
HERE REGISTRY FIRST OF IN
OPPOSITION FOR CENTER REYES
PROPERTY NUMBER ME AS IS ONLY MY
COMMENTS WITH -- A FULL
COLLEAGUES SYDNEY FROM SARAH.
THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANY ANGER JUST IN
OPPOSITION FOR LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUST ACCOUNTABILITY
THANK YOU.
MARK NEVER WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL -- ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL
PARMALEE FOR THE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW PIECE THANK YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON FOR SPHERICAL
CALIFORNIA -- WE LIKE TO HONOR
COMMENTS WAS HE'LL CV THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BRIAN WILKIE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GINA ROBINSON WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ARRIVES OVER AND BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
SOME OF HIS OFFICE -- HEAD
QUESTION WHERE I WAS ON THIS
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER
BEEN AGAINST THE BUILDING TRADES
AND WITH THE ABC -- SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BECAUSE
ABSOLUTELY ON THAT ONE PROVISION
I WANT TO BE CLEAR EIGHT THAT IS
THE ONLY THING I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
IN THIS BILL -- AND SO I THINK.
THE AUTHOR.
FOR TAKING THAT ON I CAN'T AT
THIS POINT SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I'M SORRY -- I CAN'T I COULD
SUPPORT IT IF WE WERE ONLY
TALKING ABOUT THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT SO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS WITH OVER TWENTY
FIVE UNITS I COULD -- I COULD
GET BEHIND AN EXPEDITED REVIEW.
FOR BUT I THINK AS AS DESCRIBED --
THIS IS FAR BIGGER THAN THAT MY
PROBLEM ALWAYS WITH -- EXPEDITED
REVIEW AND SEE WHAT IS QUITE
FRANKLY -- THE FACT THAT WE LACK
ANY WAY OF OF FROM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN A IN A
ECONOMIC JUSTICE STANDPOINT.
OF INVOLVING OURSELVES IN THE
PROCESS WITHOUT SEEK.
ONE SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE I DON'T I I THINK
THAT THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO IN ORDER TO HAVE A VOICE
IS HEARD ON DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
THAT.
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT -- LOW
INCOME AREAS THAT SOMETIMES.
ALL DEVELOPMENT IS NOT GOOD YOU
KNOW AND ALL JOBS ARE NOT GOOD --
AND SO BRINGING THINGS INTO A
COMMUNITY JUST BASED ON THE IDEA
THAT WE'RE GOING TO INVEST IN A
COMMUNITY.
SOMETIMES SOUNDS GOOD -- AT THE
MACRO LEVEL BUT IN PLACE IS NOT
GOOD SO I WANT TO PRESERVE THOSE
TOOLS -- FOR THOSE IN A LOCAL
AREA I I LIVE IN A DISTRICT THAT.
I THINK THIS ENTIRE AREA COVERS --
AT ALMOST EVERY CENSUS TRACT IS
IS ACTUALLY ENACTED IN IN.
AN IMPOVERISHED AREA SO -- I I
AT THIS POINT CAN'T SUPPORTED I
ABSOLUTELY ON BE CLEAR ON THE
RECORD WOULD SUPPORT A EXPEDITED
REVIEW SEQUENCE EMPTION -- FOR
HOUSING PROJECT THAT HAD
PREVAILING WAGE.
COMPONENTS TO IT BUT FOR NOW I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SENATE JONES SAWYER -- SO I
THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
CLARIFICATION -- THAT I PROBABLY
NEED IN.
AND SOME OTHER THINGS LOOK OUT
NOT TO BE TOTALLY HYPOCRITICAL
AYE I WAS LOOKING WHEN I FIRST
GOT HERE.
I WANTED TO DO.
A A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
SEQUEL CERTAINTY.
I'M AN INDIVIDUAL I WAS DIRECTOR
WILL STAY FOR THE CITY OF LA.
I'M ONE MOST EXASPERATING THINGS.
THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
USED TO DO TO ME WHEN I TRY TO
BUILD A FIRE STATION LIBRARY FOR
A POLICE STATION.
THEY WILL COME OUT AND OPPOSED.
DOES THE GODS BUILDINGS AND TO
OPPOSE OF LIBRARY JUST DIDN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME WHATSOEVER.
BUT THEY HAD THE ABILITY TO QUIT
SEQUEL TO BE ABLE TO SUE THE
CITY DELAY THE PROJECT.
DELAY LIBRARY.
OR DELAY SCHOOL.
IT JUST IT JUST DROVE ME CRAZY.
AND AND SO I I NEVER WANTED US.
TO NOT GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
CYCLE PROCESS.
BUT THE TAKE TEN YEARS TO BUILD
SOMETHING.
BECAUSE SOMEONE SUES AND ENSUED
THEY LOSE THAT SUIT AND A SU
AGAIN AND SEWER AGAIN.
WHICH TO DRIVE ME NUTS AND RISEN
DRAMATICALLY I WAS THE ONE THAT
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROJECT
AND AND NOT GETTING DONE.
IT IS DIFFERENT WHEN.
IT'S YOUR MONEY.
AND YOUR ON THE HOOK AS OPPOSED
TO THE OTHER SIDE.
AND SO I KNOW YOU HAVE EXPEDITED
I KNOW WITH MY FRIENDS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY IS BASED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY --
WHEN I SAY SEEK WITH CERTAINTY
WHICH MEANS YOU GO THROUGH ALL
THE TRAPS WITHIN GOVERNMENT
PLANNING BUILDING SAFETY?
PUBLIC WORKS FIRE DEPARTMENT.
THAT ONCE YOU FINISH THAT
PROCESS YOU CAN THEN BILLS --
FOR THEM FOR SOME PEOPLE THAT'S
THAT'S EXPEDITE. TO ME THAT'S
THE CERTAINTY OF HAJJI CHARETTE
YOU HAD TO PULL DISCUSSION WITH
THE COMMUNITY AND YOU'RE DONE.
WE DON'T RE HASH IT ALL OVER
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN AND SO --
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT GOING
FOR IT NOW.
I WOULD LIKE SOME CLARIFICATION
ON WHAT.
EXPEDITED MEANS BOTH FROM YOUR
SIDE AND THE OTHER SIDE. TO IS A
LABOR PERSON I GUESS SOME
DISTRESSING THINGS I WAS HEARING
SO I WOULD LIKE THAT CLARIFIED
FOR ME ALSO -- BECAUSE I USED TO
HELP GET THOSE SHEETS IN THE
CITY OF LA TO PUT MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE.
WE'RE PAYING THE APPROPRIATE
WAGES AND AND WE HAD A WHOLE
DEPARTMENT THAT WASN'T.
YOU KNOW BILL CONTRACT
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS THEIR
SOLE JOB AS YOU KNOW -- TO TO
ENSURE THAT MIGHT WE PAID NOT
ONLY PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY
BUT WE PAY THEM THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND THEY
ACTUALLY GOT PAID BY THE PRIME
TO SELL.
SO -- PROBABLY KNOW MORE ABOUT
THIS THAN I EVER WANTED TO IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE -- AND SO I I WANT
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION I
THINK IT WILL ALSO BE GOOD.
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER BEEN AGAINST
LISTENING TO THE COMMUNITY AND
HAVING THEM.
A MEETING TO TALK ABOUT VIRAL
JUSTICE CLAIMS SO THE REASON I
WANTED TO DO THIS IN A BROADER.
I WANTED IF YOU LIVE IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
SEEK WITH CERTAINTY.
BECAUSE I FIRMLY BELIEVE THE
REASON IN SOUTH LA WHICH I
REPRESENTING PEOPLE WERE
COMMENTING ON WHERE I LIVE SO I
FELT I SHOULD COMMENT.
TO I DON'T HAVE A MALL.
I DON'T HAVE A MOVIE THEATER.
I DON'T HAVE SIT DOWN
RESTAURANTS.
BUT I DO KNOW.
I ALSO DON'T HAVE ANY BIG BOX.
THE MY DISTRICT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT WALMART
BUTTON TOM HAVE ANY BIG BOX.
AND I KNOW IF IF WE HAD SEEK
WITH CERTAINTY NAY ONLY TOOK ONE
YEAR. TO BUILD A RESTAURANT IN
MY A SIT DOWN RESTAURANT IN MY
DISTRICT AS OPPOSED TO TAKING
MAYBE TEN YEARS ON THE WEST SIDE
OF LA.
OR MORE IN SANTA MONICA SOME
CASES.
YES WE'RE GOING TO BUILD WILL
START GETTING SOME OF THOSE
SERVICES THAT WE DON'T HAVE AT
ALL RIGHT NOW SELF TO LIKE.
AND SO I I CAN.
WERE LINKING WITH OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS WHICH IS A LARGE PART OF MY
DISTRICT -- MAKES SENSE BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE -- THAT
WE WE DO THIS IN A WAY THAT.
MY COMMUNITY GET LEFT OUT RIGHT
TO GENTRIFICATION PORTION OF
THAT IS A HUGE CONCERN OF MINE
RIGHT NOW IS PROBABLY THE THE
MOST DANGEROUS PART OF WHAT'S
GOING ON SOUTH LA -- I'M WORRIED
THAT SOUTH DELAY WILL BE WHITE
AGAIN SO I DO.
I AM YES I DO HAVE SOME ISSUES.
OF THAT WEEK WE DISPLACE THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A
VERY VERY LONG TIME BECAUSE THE
HOUSING STOCK IS LOW RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE COME BY.
AND THEN WE'LL GET PRICED OUT.
IS GONNA BE DIFFERENT LOOKING
IMP GROUP OF PEOPLE THERE.
AND SO.
SIT DOWN RESTAURANTS PERHAPS
AMERICAN LATINOS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND SO WITH THAT OF A HOPEFULLY
GETS OUT HERE SO THAT WE CAN
THEN CONTINUE A CONVERSATION WE
CAN MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
I I DON'T KNOW WILL HAPPEN ON
THE FLOOR BUT DEFINITELY -- I
THINK YOU DESERVE SOME MORE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
A YOU KNOW I I I REPEATED THAT
THIS.
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
SYKORA.
BECAUSE PEOPLE KEEP REPEATING
THAT WERE WERE TRAMPLING ON C.
CLASS AND ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
SOMEBODY SAID IT WAS A EIGHT MS.
AND WORSE THAN TRAMPLING ON SEA
QUEST.
IT DOESN'T DO THAT YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS.
ALL IT DOES AND IN SO JUST JUST
BY WAY OF REFERENCES -- BLACK
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY A
COUPLE YEARS AGO LAST YEAR IN
THE YEAR BEFORE I DID A SEEK I
DID A SECRET STREAMLINING BILL.
BECAUSE I FIGURED THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT THAT'S IT
LET'S LET STREAMLINED THE SEQUEL
PROCESS SO IT HAPPENS FASTER.
AND AND I AND I TOOK A LOT OF
HEAT FOR THAT SO I I I THE
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY TO USE
PRIVATE DOLLARS.
IN OUR POOREST COMMUNITIES.
IS SEVEN YEARS WHERE I YEARS
PAST NOW -- IF IT TAKES TEN
YEARS TO BUILD THAT SIT DOWN
RESTAURANT GUESS WHAT.
THERE IS NOT GONNA BE ANY
INVESTMENT IN OUR POOREST
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT HIS
CALIFORNIA DEN. FOR OUR
DESIGNATED ZONES WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY ZERO WE HAVEN'T WE
HAVEN'T SAID WE'RE GOING TO
CREATE THIS OPPORTUNITY WE'RE
GONNA PUT MONEY WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON ON BUILDING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
AND SO ON SO CITIES ARE LEFT.
TRYING TO DO THE BEST THEY CAN
SOME OF WE DID WE USED TO DO IT
THROUGH THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
THOSE ARE GONE.
AND AND THIS IS PRIVATE DOLLARS
AND SO SO -- SO NOT ONLY DO WE
HAVE TO DO SEEK WHAT.
BUT WE TOOK AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
THE HIGHEST -- LEED
CERTIFICATION WITH NO GHG.
EMISSIONS CREATED AND AND AND
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT BECAUSE I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE BUILDING TO
THE HIGHEST STANDARDS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES -- AND AND I'M HAPPY
TO ADD THAT THE PROTECTION --
FOR LABOR AS WELL AND AND WE'LL
LOOK INTO THE LOCAL HIGHER
ORDINANCE FRANKLY.
THAT'S AN OVERSIGHT -- I'VE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED LOCAL HIGHER
ORDINANCES THOSE ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT -- AND IN IN REGARDS
TO THE COMMITMENT TO THE TO HAVE
A STAKE HOLDERS MEETING
ABSOLUTELY WE DO THAT ALL THE
TIME AND WE'VE HAD SOME MEETINGS.
THE KEY IS NOT TO MOVE THE GOAL
POSTS BECAUSE WHAT I WAS HEARING
FRANKLY IF WE CAN GET LUXURY
HOTELS IN TO SOME OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT'S THAT'S T. O. T. THAT'S
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAX IT
REALLY IS -- IS GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY BUT BUT SO WE CAN
DISAGREE OR AGREE OR DISAGREE ON
ON SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION IT AND
AND I'M WILLING TO TO CALL IT
OUT.
AND TO SAY WE'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN IN -- IN -- A BATTERY PLANT
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT NOT INTERESTED
IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND IF
WE CAN ARTICULATE THEM IN A WAY --
THAT -- THAT BAD BRING SOME
SUPPORT WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
DO THAT BUT THAT THAT THE THE
OTHER THING THAT THAT I GET VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT.
IS IN ONE OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE SENATE I WAS
ASKED IF I WOULD MAKE IT A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND YOU KNOW I JUST GOT TO SAY
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW TALKING
ABOUT OVER CONCENTRATION OF OF
POOR PEOPLE IN A IN AN ALREADY
POOR COMMUNITY AND SO -- SO I'M
TRYING TO BE BALANCED -- I'M
TRYING TO GET A NUMBER THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS WERE GOING TO GET
IT THE INVESTMENT OF PRIVATE
FUNDS AND I REALLY APPRECIATE --
YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE WHAT WE
HAVE DONE IS NOT.
NOT TINKERED WITH WITH SECRET
ALL WE'VE JUST SAD IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SUE ON IT.
THERE'S IT'S AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS IN THE COURTS GOT IT THE
COURT'S GOTTA GET TO IT M..
WITHIN A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
DAYS IF THEY CAN'T TO CAN TAKE
LONGER BUT WE WANT WE WANT WE
WANT CERTAINTY THAT'S THAT'S A
CERTAIN TO YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
AND I I'VE HAD WAY TOO MANY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PERENNIALLY OPPOSED.
ON ON SEEK WELL IN THE CHASE
AWAY THE DEVELOPERS IS WHAT IT
AMOUNTS TO SO.
WELL UP IN CENTER AYE AYE THE
PURSE I PUSH IT WORK ON THIS AND
AS WELL AS WORK IN THE BUILDING
TRADES ON THIS WHEN THIS.
BILL FIRST CROSSED MY DESK -- I
CERTAINLY HAD CONCERNS OF THIS
IS THE LABOR EMPLOYMENT MEANS
WE'RE FOCUSING MORE ON THE LABOR
CONCERNS -- AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF MOVEMENT THAT ALLOWS
ACTUALLY THE BILL REACHES A BEER
SPEAKING SUPPORT.
AND SO I WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
REALLY BE TAKING TO HEART THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED --
AND AS THIS -- BUT IF IT GETS
THROUGH IT'S GOING TO NATURAL
RESOURCES SO I'M I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS REYES I
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO GET A FULL
VETTING.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
AS WE CAN IMAGINE BUT I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL TO HEAR IT HERE --
IN ADVANCE OF THE GOING TO
NATURAL RESOURCES BECAUSE THOSE
ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT I
THINK -- YOU KNOW THE THE THE
NATURAL RESOURCES CHAIR AND HER
COMMITTEE I KNOW I'M GOING TO
PUT A LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY --
TO INTO JUST AS WE HAVE ON THE
LABOR ASPECT OF THIS AND SO.
THAT IS WHY THERE IS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION OF WITH THE A
MAN'S THAT -- BUT I'VE COME THAT
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED.
BY THE AUTHOR OF WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE CONTINUE TO WORK AND
CONVERSATION -- ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION FOR
INDICATING THAT THEY LOOK FOR TO
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
BECAUSE THIS STILL HAS A LONG
WAY TO GO BEFORE I GUESS THE
ASSEMBLY FOR I THINK.
ALL OF US UP YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
MORE OF THAT MOVEMENT AND THAT
CONVERSATION AS WE GO FORWARD
AND BUT I THINK.
AS EVIDENCED BY WHAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENED IN THE RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME THERE'S BEEN --
BEEN VETTED BY THE LABOR --
COMMITTEE I I THINK THAT YOU
SHOWN THAT YOU CAN LOOK BILLION
TO MAKE -- THOSE COMPROMISES --
IT BECAUSE I THINK YOUR GOALS
LAUDABLE -- BUT I THINK THAT THE
WAY IT'S DONE OF COURSE IS WHERE
THAT THE DETAILS ARE WITH THE
DETAILS LIKE -- LIKE IT GIVES US
A SPACE TO TO EITHER SUPPORT OR
NOT AS A GUEST OF THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
AND SO -- THERE WAS I KNOW WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU STARTED SPEAKING
THERE WAS OF A MOTION BY OUR
VICE CHAIR AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE WAS A SECOND -- IT SOME OF
MOTION BYE BYE SURE FOR AS OUR
SECOND.
A SIMILAR CARILLO IS THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENT OR QUESTION FOR
MANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF NOT ABOVE SENATOR I DON'T
KNOW IF THE LAST COMMENT WAS
YOUR CLOTHES IF YOU LIKE TO DO
ANY FOR THEIR CLOTHES GOOD
MORNING Là.
AB WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK THANK YOU
CENTER AND SO WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION MADAM SECRETARY TO
TAKE THE ROLE PLEASE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I AGREE YOU.
I THE UP.
YEP I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ NO JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
AND SO THAT BILLS OUT SO THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APPRECIATE THE GOOD THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION DURING THIS
HEARING [inaudible]
SENDER BRADFORD.
CENTER BRADFORD SB TO A TEAM.
OF THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SOME NYQUIL
THE SECOND MY SUMMER GONZALEZ.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE I'LL BE BRIEF SB TWO
EIGHTEEN ALLOWS LOCAL JERKS DICK
J. JURISDICTION TO ENFORCE STATE.
PROHIBITING -- EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN AN ACTOR OWN
ANTI DISCRIMINATION.
COMMISSION LOS AN ORDINANCE --
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES.
ARE CURRENTLY ONLY DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR HOUSING AND HAS THAT
AUTHORITY UNDER STATE -- AND THE
STATE'S ONLY ABLE TO ENFORCE
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS -- LAST
YEAR I INTRODUCED ONE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN I INTRODUCED OUR
SB.
FOUR NINETY ONE AND THE GOVERNOR
CONVENE A ADVISORY TASK FORCE
YOU CAME UP WITH THE FOLLOWING
THAT STATE TO CITIES ARE CAPABLE
OF DOING THIS.
I WILL -- TRUNCATE MY
PRESENTATION A LOT MY TWO
WITNESSES -- TO TELL THEIR
TESTIMONY ARE WE HAVE ON YES
HARRIS.
AND FROM THE LA BLACK WORKERS
CENTER AND JESSICA BUT THE FAR
LITTLE BIRTH ARE LOW I'M SORRY
FROM THE WHAT'S THE SOONER LONG
POVERTY THANK YOU THANK A
RESPECT LESS PRIVATE THANK YOU
CENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ON YES HARRIS AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES BLACK WORKER CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF AND THE NEED FOR SB.
TWO ONE EIGHT TODAY I AM HERE
BEFORE YOU AS A HIGHLY SKILLED
EDUCATED AMBITIOUS AND CURRENTLY
UNEMPLOYED MASTER DEGREE
EDUCATOR.
AFTER WORKING IN THE HIGHEST
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE AT THE
COLLEGIATE INSTITUTION FOR CLOSE.
TO FIVE I WAS TERMINATED FOR
REQUESTING A REYES.
I WAS THE ONLY PERSON OF COLOR
AND THE ONLY BLACK PERSON
WORKING FOR THE COLLEGE.
I WHILE SERVING SIMULTANEOUSLY
AS THE DIRECTOR PROFESSIONAL
CERTIFICATION DIRECTOR OF
ADMISSIONS AND REGISTRAR I
SUCCESSFULLY MAINTAIN THESE
POSITIONS WITHOUT A HIGHER UP
SUPPORT SYSTEM OR AN
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF.
AT THE BI WEEKLY SALARY OF ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS.
WHEN I WAS ASKED TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES I
REQUESTED AN INCREASE?
FROM.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS BI WEEKLY TO
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS BI
WEEKLY.
MY REQUEST WAS MET WITH
IMMEDIATE TERMINATION.
THE AVERAGE SALARY FOR DIRECTOR
OF ADMISSIONS ALONE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE DOLLARS.
MY SALARY AT THAT TIME WAS
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS
THAN THE MAJORITY OF MY
COUNTERPARTS.
I UNDERSTAND ALL TOO WELL WAGE
DISCRIMINATION AND DEGRADATION.
AND ALL MY TIME AT THIS COLLEGE
I NEVER RECEIVED A REPRIMAND NOR
ANYTHING LESS THAN AN EXCELLENT
REVIEW.
A REASSIGNMENT DUTY TASK ARE
COMPLETED WITH EXCELLENCE AND
EFFICIENCY WITHOUT EXCEPTION AND
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE WITH LITTLE
IF ANY SUPERVISION.
I CONSISTENTLY EXCEEDED
EXPECTATIONS.
I LEFT THE OFFICE I WORKED AT
FOR FOUR AND A HALF YEARS
WITHOUT A SEVERANCE PACKAGE.
LEAVING SICK TIME ACCRUED AND
JUST SHY OF BEING VESTED.
I WAS DENIED REFERENCES AS WELL
AS LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION.
I AM HERE BECAUSE I DID GO
THROUGH THE PROPER CHANNELS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT.
AND THERE WAS NOTHING THAT THEY
COULD DO IT TOOK TWO MONTHS FOR
THEM TO RESPOND TO THE ISSUES
THAT I SUBMITTED IN MY CLAIM.
I ALSO SOUGHT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION REGARDING THE
MATTER.
AND THEY SAID THAT.
THEY WERE JUST HAPPY THAT I WAS
NO LONGER AT THAT POSITION.
I'M NOT SURE IF ANY OF YOU
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS AND THE
CAREER PATH THAT A HIGHER
EDUCATION [inaudible]
CONSISTED OF WHEN YOU ARE DENIED
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION WHEN
YOU ARE DENIED.
PREFERENCES.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE?
L. STANDING TO A IT IS LIKE.
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE MEANS NOTHING?
I AM HERE.
BECAUSE THE CURRENT SYSTEMS
[inaudible]
NEED REINFORCEMENT.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANYBODY.
SHOULD HAVE TO EXPERIENCE BUT
THE EXPERIENCED.
NO MATTER WHAT LEVEL.
THEY ARE WHATEVER POSITION THEY
HOLD EDUCATED OR NOT EDUCATED.
THIS WAS A VERY DEVASTATING
EXPERIENCE AND I WOULD IMAGINE
IT'S THE SAME FOR EVERYONE.
SO AGAIN I'M HERE.
SUPPORT OF SB TWO ONE EIGHT
BECAUSE AGAIN.
CURRENT SYSTEMS NEED
REINFORCEMENT.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE -- DESK ABOUT THE FOR
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
IN SUPPORT AND AS A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
WE WERE A SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BILL AND
AND AT THE TIME THAT WE KNEW --
THAT THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS
AGAINST WORKER DISCRIMINATION
WERE BEING ERODED -- WE HAD NO
IDEA I DON'T THINK ANY OF US AS
A NATION.
THE KIND OF AND OF NATIONAL
GROSS AND SUPPORT ENDORSEMENT OF
HATE AND DISCRIMINATION -- AND
HOW TIMELY THIS BILL WOULD BE
WHEN I CAME BACK -- THE WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
MEANTIME AS CENTER BRADFORD HAS
MENTIONED -- WE THERE WAS A WORK
GROUP HELD BY THE F. B. H..
WE MET AT THE CHAMBER WAS THERE
OTHER EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY IN
ADVOCATES WERE THERE.
AND HERE IS A YEAR LONG PROCESS
THIS THE BILL THIS IMPRINT TODAY
WAS HIGHLY INFORMED BY THAT
PROCESS AND AND WHAT WORKERS ARE
ASKING.
FOR IS A PROCESS -- THAT'S
CLOSER TO HOME -- WHERE THEY CAN --
WORK WITH LEADERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AT TO GET OUT THE
WORD ABOUT IT WORKER PROTECTIONS
AND HELP IN FORCE -- WORKER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND JUST TO NOTE
THAT WORKER DISCRIMINATION
CLAIMS ARE INCREASING REPORTS OF
WORKER DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS ARE
INCREASING AN ANKLE.
IMPACTS NOT ONLY BLACK WORKERS
OF THE BLACK WORKERS ARE THE
MOST DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
WORKERS LATINO WORKERS ARE AT
THE NEXT.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH THE NEXT
HIGHEST.
LGBT Q. WORKERS ARE
DISCRIMINATED MORE THAN 40% OF
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL AND TRANS
PEOPLE HAVE REPORTED
DISCRIMINATION AT WORK.
ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE REPORTED AT
HIGH LEVELS AND INCREASING
LEVELS OF DISCRIMINATION AT WORK
AND NEWCOMERS DESPITE AMERICANS
ORIGIN AS A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS -- ARE FACING
INCREASED LEVELS OF
DISCRIMINATION AT WORK THIS IS A
TIME WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS RETREATING FROM PROTECTIONS
AGAINST WORKERS THAT WE SHOULD
BE.
MOVING FORWARD AND WE APPRECIATE.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
YES MY NAME IS MINDY GARLAND I'M
LEAD ORGANIZER WITH THE LA BLACK
WORKERS CENTER -- WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT AS BETWEEN A MAN HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU ALL
MIGHT HAVE THINK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SERRA
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DIPPING ACNE IS A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUST BECAUSE THEN -- HAVE LEGAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAELIN DEAN POLICY LINK AT THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS MEN OF COLOR
IN SUPPORT PROUD CO SPONSORS
THANK YOU.
KIM MORE YOU W. PROUD CO
SPONSORS WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BETTER
BECOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL -- AND CONCERNED ABOUT
UNCERTAINTY AN INCONSISTENCY IT
COULD CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WAS PART OF
THE ESPY FORTY FOUR NINETY ONE
ADVISORY.
GROUP THAT TOOK A LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE AND THAT WHILE THAT REPORT
SAID THAT LOCAL ENFORCEMENT OF
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS IS
FEASIBLE.
IT ALSO SAID QUOTE IF THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD DECIDE TO
ALLOW FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT DE
IF EACH WOULD URGE THAT CAREFUL
ATTENTION BE PAID TO THE
PRACTICAL POLICY CONSIDERATIONS.
DISCUSSED BELOW AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE BILL -- HAS
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED THOSE
CONCERNS AND LIKE TO BRING A
COUPLE TO YOUR ATTENTION.
NUMBER ONE WERE CONCERNED
THERE'S GONNA BE INCONSISTENCY
AN APPLICATION OF THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
THIS BILL ALLOWS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ACCEPT AND
INVESTIGATE CLAIMS AND OF THE
STATE WIDE.
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT
AND A SET FORTH ON PAGE ELEVEN
OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE REPORT
THIS CAN CREATE SEVERAL
CHALLENGES.
INCLUDING LACK OF CONSISTENCY
REGARDING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS LACK OF CONSISTENCY
WITH REGARD TO PROCEDURAL
REGULATIONS LACK OF CONSISTENCY
IN THE APPLICATION AND
INTERPRETATION OF THE STATEWIDE
BOX -- AND QUOTING FROM PAGE
ELEVEN OF THAT REPORT.
THEY SAID CALIFORNIANS IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS WOULD
EFFECTIVELY BE SUBJECT TO
DIFFERENT LAWS FOR INSTANCE A
HYPOTHETICAL CITY OF LOS ANGELES
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMISSION COULD
INTERPRET THE SAME PROVISIONS OF
FEET HIGH.
DIFFERENTLY FROM HYPOTHETICAL
SAN FRANCISCO CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMISSION.
NOR CAN IT BE ASSUME THAT ANY
CITY WOULD INTERPRET THE FEET
HIGH IN THE SAME WAY THAT HE IF
HE H. WOULD.
CALIFORNIANS IN DIFFERENT
REGIONS WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
DIFFERENT PROCEDURES IT'S A WE
DON'T BELIEVE THOSE CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED
IN THIS BILL.
BUT WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED WITH
THE LOCAL PATCHWORK OF ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS -- THIS BILL
ALLOWS LOCAL ORDINANCES TO ADOPT
THEIR OWN -- ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS.
YOU KNOW FROM AN EMPLOYER'S
PERSPECTIVE WE ALREADY HAVE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE LAWS PAID
SICK LEAVE LAWS BAN THE BOX LAWS
OTHER AREAS NOT THAT THERE'S ANY
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE POLICY
OBJECTIVES OF THOSE LAWS BUT IF
YOU'RE AN EMPLOYER OPERATE IN IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO COMPLY WITH
ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT THEY'RE
ALL A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THEY
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT PROCEDURES
AND PROCESSES AND THEN THERE'S A
STATE LAW OVERLAPPING AND AS
WELL.
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ ABOUT
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF BASICALLY
WHERE YOU HAVE A STATEWIDE LAW.
A GREAT STATE WEDLOCK ANY HAVE
LOCAL ORDINANCES WELL AND THAT
CAN CREATE CONFUSION EVEN FOR
WORKERS WHO GET A PAY STUB THAT
SAYS.
STATEWIDE PAID SICK LEAVE HERE'S
YOUR SAN DIEGO PAID SICK LEAVE
IT CREATES CONFUSION AND IT'S
CONFUSING FROM A COMPLIANCE
PERSPECTIVE FROM AN EMPLOYER TO
HAVE TO COMPLY.
WITH DIFFERENT LAWS IN DIFFERENT
YOUR JURISDICTIONS IT'S A WEEK
WE FEEL LIKE THIS WOULD
EXACERBATE THAT PROBLEM. FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE SAME REASONS
IF YOU HAD -- DIFFERENT OFFICES
ARE DIFFERENT EMPLOYEES IN
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS MUCH
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
SENATORS DO FOR EXAMPLE YOUR
CAPITAL STAFF IN YOUR DISTRICT
STAFF MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT --
RULES OR DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS
WHICH WOULD BE AT DIFFICULT AND
POTENTIALLY -- GOT CONFUSING AND
COMPLICATED DISCRIMINATION IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND NEEDS TO BE --
ADDRESS WE SHOULD HAVE.
CONSISTENT STRICT RULES AND ALSO
GIVE -- EMPLOYERS AND POTENTIAL
DEFENDANTS THIS -- CONSISTENCY
AND SECURITY SAID NO CLEARLY --
WHAT THE RULES ARE SO THAT THEY
CAN FOLLOW THEM?
THANKS THANK YOU.
IS EVERYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO KITTY HAVE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST THANK YOU.
OKAY SO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AS ANY AND AND THE SECOND WE
HAVE ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
SENATOR WHICH YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
UP THANK YOU I THINK MRS HEARSES
TESTIMONY IS PROOF AND ITSELF
THAT HOW IMPORTANT IS MEASURE IS
I KNOW THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND I KNOW IT'S GREAT
CONCERN WITH HAVING A HODGEPODGE
OF A DIFFERENT LAWS I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE.
THE CASE I THINK THEY'RE GONNA
USED.
TO CONSTRUCT OF WHAT THE HOUSE
STATES AND INTERPRETED JUST ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND AND NOT
CREATE THEIR OWN.
POLICIES IN PROCESS THAT RUNNING
A SKEW THAT SO ON THAT NOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- MANCHESTER
OF CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA CARILLO
[inaudible]
I YEP.
INDIA I IN SALAS CAN SALAS AYE
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D THREE OF US.
BUT THAT WAS THE LONGEST PAUSE
FOR AND I DON'T.
KNOW.
I APPRECIATED THE BILL.
YOU KNOW MAYBE COME OVER THE THE
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR.
IF WE CANNOT PROMOTION ON THE TO
CONSENT ITEMS AND OF CENTER
GALGIANI PLEASE TAKE A SEAT IN
THE MEANTIME.
WE HAVE -- SB THREE SIXTY TWO
FROM PENN SB SIX NINETY BUT
LEYVA.
A MOST FROM SUMMER CREEL AS OUR
SECOND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE'S A SECOND FROM THE SUMMER
GONZALEZ -- MATTER SECTOR TO
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS.
SB THREE SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
ON THREE SIXTY THREE IS TO PASS
CONSENT TO HEALTH COMMITTEE.
AN S. P. SIX NINETY EIGHT IS DO
PASS -- TO APPROPRIATIONS
CONSENT.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
IDEA.
YEP HI GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT --
ITEM SIX SB FIVE THIRTY SENATE
GALGIANI PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB FIVE THIRTY
WILL REQUIRE THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
SHOULD DEVELOP AN INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION PREVENTION POLICY
FOR USE BY EMPLOYERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
ONGOING REVELATIONS UNDERSCORED
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WIDESPREAD
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EXISTS WITHIN
VIRTUALLY EVERY INDUSTRY.
THESE INCIDENTS UNDERMINE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OUR STATE HAS MADE
TOWARDS GENDER EQUITY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
SB FIVE THIRTY ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC ANTI
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
POLICY TRAINING STANDARDS FOR
USE BY CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS.
DIRECTLY ADDRESSING THE ON GOING
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
ISSUES ON THE JOB SITE WILL
ENSURE ALL WORKERS ARE TREATED
FAIRLY AND WILL HELP CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF THE INDUSTRY.
I'LL BE SUBMITTING AMENDMENTS
AND APPROPRIATIONS TO CLARIFY
THE TIME FRAME FOR RECEIVING THE
TRAINING.
THE MESSAGE METHODS BY WHICH AN
EMPLOYER CAN PROVIDE THE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
GRAMMATICAL CHANGES WITH ME
TODAY IS SATURDAY YES AT THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
MEASURE MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER
BEHALF F THE STATE BILL AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL --
BUT WE WERE THANKFUL FOR CENTER
GALGIANI RE INTRODUCING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IT WAS
ACTUALLY COMPANION BILL TO A
BILL THAT -- SOMEONE WILL
MCCARTY -- RAN IT WILL SIGNED
LAST YEAR OFFER TECHNICAL ISSUES
DID NOT GET SIGNED UP PRIMARILY
BECAUSE IT WAS HOUSE AT THE OF
WAS NOT HOUSE AT THE FE H. BUT
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
BECAUSE IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY MOST OF OUR WORK IS
DONE THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL.
RELATIONS SO WE'RE SPECIFICALLY
TRYING TO DO IS TO CREATE A
CONSTRUCTION SPECIFIC TYPE OF
POLICY WHERE -- SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CAN BE DEALT WITH IN
A IN A MANNER THAT ACTUALLY
WORKS AND ONE EXAMPLE THAT WE'RE%
TRYING TO DO HERE WITH THE BILL
IS THAT.
A A PIECE OF LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR BY SENATOR
MITCHELL DEALING WITH TRAINING --
FOR EMPLOYEES ONE HOUR TRAINING
FOR EVERY NEW HIRE -- WITHIN THE
SIX MONTHS WELL IN THE UNIONIZED
INDUSTRY MULTI EMPLOYER A
DIFFERENT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS OUR MEMBERS ARE
WORKING FOR MULTIPLE EMPLOYERS
WITHIN THE SIX MONTH PERIOD.
AND SO UNDER THOSE PROVISIONS WE
WOULD HAVE TO THE HAVE OUR
MEMBERS RETRAIN OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO TWO PARTS TO THIS BILL ONE
PART IS.
TO SELECT THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND STATE
AGENCIES PROVIDING FEEDBACK ON
HOW TO CREATE THOSE POLICIES ARE
AMEND THE POLICIES ARE AN
EXISTING CODE TODAY.
AND ALSO CREATE NEW ONE SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE A BETTER JOB SITE
ENVIRONMENT FOR EVERYONE
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN WHICH WE ARE
ACTIVELY TRYING TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY.
AND TO WE HAVE DONE SOME IN
ROADS BUT WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
THE SECOND PIECE IS TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE TRAINING THAT I
REFERENCE EARLIER IN MY COMMENTS.
I THINK IS A VERY GOOD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD CHANGE
JOBS I CULTURE ENCOURAGE MORE
WOMEN TO JOIN THE TRADES FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRETT BARROW REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS A NATIONAL
LIBERAL CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL PLAN HE BE HEATING AND
PIPING INDUSTRY.
UNITED CONTRACTORS AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LA TRADES
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND JUST ECHO WHAT
MISTER DE AS A SAID.
YOU KNOW WE ARE A MULTI AN
EMPLOYER OF CONSTRUCT AND WE
RARELY DO WE FIND EMPLOYEES ON
JOBS LONGER THAN.
OF SIX MONTHS TO YEAR -- THERE
IT'S HIGHLY MOBILE SO THAT THAT
THAT MOBILIZATION PROVISION IS
IS KEY OF A KEEP IMPORTANCE TO
US SO WITH THAT I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
OF CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY QUESTION REPRESENTING
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE IS ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS MOTIONS.
OKAY.
OKAY SPILL MOTION A SECOND YES
IMMIGRANT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR US
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL BACK.
INTO THE PROCESS -- I DO BELIEVE
IN AGREE WITH THE TRAITS THAT
THERE IS A VERY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF COLOR. TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A GOOD JOB A
LONG TERM AND BE SUSTAINABLE TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES I LOVE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR WINS OUR TIMES
CONVENIENCE.
THANK YOU.
I APOLOGIZE SO I'D I'D SKIPPED
OPPOSITION AND SO I WELL WILL --
GO JUMP BACK REALLY QUICK AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT -- OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS RICHARD MARKETS AND WE
CERTAINLY AGREE ON BEHALF THE
WESTERN ELECTRIC CONTRACTORS WE
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSOR.
OF THAT THE TREATMENT OF WOMEN A
CAN BE.
A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM ON
CONSTRUCTION WORK SITE.
A WE DO AGREE WITH THE PRINCIPLE
OF CREATING A INDUSTRY SPECIFIC
TRAINING ARE ONLY OBJECTION A
COMES FROM THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL THAT LIMIT THE
AUTHORITY OR THE ABILITY OF ONLY.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT TO PROVIDE PROVIDE THE
TRAINING.
MY CLIENTS ALL OF PROVIDE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING -- AND
WHILE MOST OF THE JOURNEY
WORKERS FOR ARE EMPLOYING
CONTRACTORS I HAVE A FAIRLY
CONSISTENT POINT.
RECORD WITH THOSE A CONTRACTORS.
THE APPRENTICE'S DUE TRAVEL FROM
OF WORK SITE TO WORK SITE FROM
EMPLOYER TO EMPLOYER WE THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE AND THERE IS NO NEED
TO LIMIT.
OF THE TRAINING AUTHORITY TO
ONLY THOSE -- OPPRESSION OF
PROVIDERS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT --
WE BELIEVE THAT ANY PRESSURE
PROGRAM THAT'S APPROVED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SHOULD BE PERMITTED TO
PROVIDE THE TRAINING.
WE ALL APPLY.
AND COMPLY WITH THE SAME --
INDUSTRY STANDARDS UP FOR A
TRAINING THE APPRENTICES AND WE
THINK THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THAT
WOULD BE ADDED TO THE CURRICULUM
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK ANY
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- SOME OF HIS OFFICE I
JUST HAD A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
WOULD THAT BE OF ONE OF THE
COURSES YOU.
CHARGE APPRENTICES FOR OR WOULD
THIS BE A NEW FREE COURSE.
AS I'M SURE YOU ARE AWARE WE
DON'T CHARGE OUR PRACTICES FOR
ANY TRAINING IT IS FULLY
EMPLOYER PAID -- WAR WE DO
RECEIVE A MODEST CONTRIBUTION
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THE RELATED SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION -- OUR PRACTICES
LEAVE THE PROGRAM WITH ZERO DEBT
AND HAVING MADE NO PAYMENTS
DURING THE ENTIRE COURSE OF
THEIR ENROLLMENT AS AN
APPRENTICE.
I THINK THAT THAT'S I THANK YOU
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE
COURSES I'VE SEEN OFFERED AT A
PRICE SO IT'S GOOD TO HEAR THAT --
BUT WE DEFINITELY AT LEAST IN
THE PAST HAVE SEEN THE CHARGING
FOR CLASSES -- THAT IS DIFFERENT
WELL THAT MUST BE A NEW.
A NEW FEATURE THAT YOU'RE
OFFERING AND I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT.
BECAUSE THERE DEFINITELY WAS.
THE R. A. B. C. PARTNERS IF YOU
WELL DEFINITELY.
CHARGED -- FOLKS TO GO THROUGH A
TRAINING PROGRAM IN ORDER TO
BECOME APPRENTICES.
MY CLIENTS HAVE NEVER CHARGE FOR
PROTECTION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I WILL ADD.
WITH WHICH I OKAY THANK YOU SO
AS I SOON THOSE WILL BE FREE
COURSES.
IF YOU EVER HAVE BEEN GRANTED.
AND SO -- ONE OF THE THANK YOU
CENTER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK HAVING INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC -- TRAINING IS
APPROPRIATE I ALSO THINK IT WILL
BE A LESSEN THE BURDEN ON SOME
OF THE EMPLOYERS THAT ALSO HAVE
TO DO TRAINING. FOR FOR FOLKS
MIGHT BE THERE FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND INSTEAD WE
ARE CERTAIN THAT.
THOSE ARE WORKING ON THE SET ARE
GETTING APPROPRIATE TRAINING I
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT A LITTLE LATER WE NEED A
LITTLE WORK ON THE LANGUAGE THAT
CAN CERTAINLY BE DONE.
AS THIS GOES FORWARD IT WILL BE
IF PASSED WHEN APPROPRIATIONS
I'M SURE APPROPRIATIONS CHERYL
MAKE SURE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE DONE AN APPROPRIATE MANNER --
ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
IF NOT WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THE
RELIGION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU.
MA'AM SECTOR CALL ROLL PLEASE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO [inaudible]
REAL IDEA.
YEP I CAN SALAS.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
WHAT THE BILL'S OUT -- SET OF
THANK YOUS UNDERMINING SB.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT I WANT TO STICK
ROSE AGAIN I HAD THREE BILLS AND
HEALTH AT ONE BILL THAT JUST GOT
PRESENTED LEFT.
AND SO CENTER MINING -- OF THE
BILL I WITH THE THANK YOU MOTION
TO DO PASSAGE TO SHERRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
BRIEFLY CURRENTLY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS UNPAID MINIMUM IN
OVERTIME WAGES THROUGH A
CITATION ISSUED TO THE EMPLOYER.
THESE CITATIONS MAY BE
PROSECUTED TOGETHER IN A SINGLE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING WHEN
THE CITATIONS ARE APPEALED.
CONTRACT WAGES HOWEVER MAY BE
ENFORCED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ONLY THROUGH A
CIVIL ACTION FILED IN SUPERIOR
COURT.
SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT GIVES THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER THE AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS UNPAID CONTRACTUAL
WAGES THROUGH A CITATION ISSUE
AGAINST AN EMPLOYER.
THIS BILL ONE SURE WORKERS ARE
PAID THEIR APPROPRIATE
CONTRACTUAL WAGES IN A TIMELY
MANNER -- BY PERMITTING I'M PAID
CONTRACT WE JUST TO BE COLLECTED
THROUGH THE ISSUANCE OF
CITATIONS.
IT ALSO MAKES IT EASIER FOR AN
EMPLOYER WHO APPEALS TO
CONSOLIDATE ACTIONS AND NOT BE
DRAGGED INTO SUPERIOR COURT --
SO THAT IT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE 2%.
NOW A PERMANENT FIXTURE OF YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CAESAR THE S.
SO WE GET A NAME PLATE -- I
APOLOGIZE -- THIRTY IS ON BEHALF
OF THE PROVIDING VERY MEAN FOR
THE TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE IT IS A MISNOMER THAT --
ONLY WORKERS IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY OR VERY LOW WAGE WORKERS
ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT ARE BEING
ABUSED BY EMPLOYERS -- THERE'S
BEEN NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT HAVE
CITED BANKS -- RESTAURANTS --
CORPORATIONS BASICALLY NOT
PROVIDING -- THEIR OBLIGATIONS
NOT MEETING THEIR OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE WEIGHT STANDARDS TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES -- THERE IS A A
SAN JOSE MERCURY NEWS --
EDITORIAL OR STUDY THAT WAS --
PROVIDED -- WHERE IT WAS VERY
DETAILED AS TO HOW MANY OF THESE
EMPLOYERS ACTUALLY ARE VERY
COMMON IN CALIFORNIA?
AND SO WE WERE VERY THANKFUL FOR
MISTER CENTER A CENTER MORNING
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE WHICH IS --
YOU KNOW NOT THE FOCUS OF MANY
PIECES OF LEGISLATION WITH
REGARDS TO YOUR WORKERS THAT ARE
UNDER CONTRACTUAL WAGES BUT ARE
STILL BEING DENIED THE PROPER
WAGES OUT FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CAN WAY ON BEHALF CALIFORNIAN
PLAMEN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR SERVE
LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THEY WILL OPPOSITION.
MMHM CAPER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR I THINK IT'S A GREAT
EAGLE IT WAS A CLOSE PRECIADO IT
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OF MANAGE SUCH A CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I REAL.
CARILLO IDEA.
I THANK AND SALAS.
GONZALEZ I DON'T SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
OKAY SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND SO WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL
WHICH IS SB ONE SEVENTY ONE BY --
SIR JACKSON.
SB ONE SEVENTY ONE CURRENT
MOTION DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY
ABSENT MEMBERS CARILLO.
CARILLO I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI.
OKAY SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND IF WE CAN THAT WE HAVE A A
NUMBER OF BILLS -- THAT ARE OUT
W. SPEAKING HAVE ADD ON'S RIGHT
NOW.
SEE SB TWENTY FIVE UP SOME
MEMBER THREE OF US SB.
ONE FORTY TWO OF SOME MEMBERS
CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO HI.
SB TWO EIGHTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING THREE OF US.
AT SB. SIX THREE SIXTY THREE
THAT'S CONSENT CALENDAR OF SOME
MEMBERS FLORA.
I FLORA AYE THREE OF US
[inaudible]
SB.
HELIS RESPONSE.
SB -- SEVEN THIRTY ABSENT
MEMBERS CARILLO [inaudible]
RIO HI
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE ONLY ONES THAT.
NOT.
LONG AFTER.
THAT.
YEAH [inaudible]
YOUR TODAY.
YEAH THIS MESSAGE.
YEAH.
I HAD TO PUT YOUR BILL BUT I'M
GOING
.
TO YEAH AT ARMS.
JUST.
LOOK AT THIS FROM THE BEGINNING
RIGHT.
YOU GOT IT SIR.
SB -- TWENTY FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS
THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US HI.
SB TWO EIGHTEEN UPS A MEMBER
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB.
THREE SIXTY THREE THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI.
SB FIVE THIRTY OF SOME MEMBER
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I SB SIX EIGHT EIGHT
APPS MEMBER THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
MADE IS A JOURNEY